foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
are we there we're here I wasn't even
[__] done arranging [__] man uh hold
on you're seeing backstage kids
I gotta pull up the hello
the YouTube of it all so that I can keep
up with the chat all right there we are
and we're here uh
hey everybody welcome
to another fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Mark Bernard hey
oh
this ain't an ad or anything but I just
ordered a [__] shake from plant power
yeah is they use vanilla only as the
base and they put peanut butter in it
I'm [__]
charged son I'm so
I'm so peanut buttered up man it was a
bag of peanut butter smoothie it was
amazing
outstanding
um I expect you will buy stock in the
company in any minute what do you think
I'm [__] fumbling around
uh Hey everybody here we are man
here to [__] answer all your
questions
in a Super Chat no here we are to uh
talk about
all things
geeky and freaky
of the wiki
um I'm your host Kevin Smith
I'm the other guy
where am I there he is the other guy I I
saw you on
the uh no other way okay that guy I saw
you uh online uh out there fighting the
good fight on behalf of the writers yet
again how often do you go to the strikes
uh I'm in every other day kind of fella
um depending on the week it's Monday
Wednesday Friday this week it's Tuesday
Thursday so I'll be back out there
tomorrow not sure where yet
um I haven't done much on your side of
the world over the hill so maybe I'll go
visit like Netflix
I fast uh
Where'd I pass uh place where they do
um what should we call it
Tom Beverly
it's at the television City yeah yeah
that place I saw people out there
yesterday I drove by and I [__] laid
on the horn and what I love about the
strike is you can [__] act all Jersey
and just [__] play on the horn and
nobody to see the [__] in fact a good
thing they all [__] they're happy and
stuff
yeah I've been doing my part been
walking the beat
uh I have not last time I walked the
beat was with you I've been away for 10
days I just got home on Monday morning
I went back east and I did some smog
Castle shows uh had a
uh what did I do the uh we showed Jaws
we showed Red State then we showed
Jersey girl and Raquel Castro came out
who is now about one year younger than
Ben was when we made
Jersey girl so the little Jersey girl
from the poster standing opposite Ben
like this is now almost Ben's age when
we made Jersey Girl
time mark it won't be stopped
um
what else did I do then I went to
Florida and my mom got out of the
hospital for the first time in 10
[__] weeks Amazing 10 weeks later
three hospitals later mom is Alive and
Well thank the Lord because there was a
moment there where it looked like well
they literally told us though like you
may need to look into hospice care
and I was like she's already in a
hospice and my brother's like she's in
the hospital you [__] idiot
and when they explained it to me of
course I was like what the
um but man she [__] recovered and uh
thanked the Lord for that so is she home
now with her cat she was you know she
has this cat
princess 20 years
she got it after my dad died and uh the
whole time my mom was in the hospital I
was like this cat must be kept alive at
all costs
closer we got to my mom getting out I
was like if this cat [__] dies today
oh no uh so she got to reunite with her
cat and it was like [__] adorable
um
then I went to Toronto did a signing at
Captain Comics
um over there in Brantford
um they're the folks that do are the
Canadian arm
of uh kev's Comics club which we do out
of that secret stash and get all
masquerades and quick stops like signed
and sent right to your house but we
never did Canada because it was too cost
prohibitive to ship but we ship our
books to Captain they ship them out so
they got a storefront as well what a
[__] great operation this is
um Jaden who's the kid and Warren is
dead
like he his one day his dad came home
from work and said [__] it I'm quitting
let's open a comic book store because
this kid was like there's a hole in the
business he's like and I think we could
fill it these
[__] geniuses
move over a thousand a comic book comic
books a day bro
oh
you know what I'm saying like every time
I come into a business where I'm like
they're doing better than me I'm like
what the [__] is the secret
um crazy
stuff each book with loonies you would
think more coonies for that matter they
uh a lot of cocaine they do a lot of
mail order and send it out across Canada
and stuff like that so not a thousand
books like in person at the you know
people walking up and stuff but I I saw
their [__] room where they have all
the books ready to be shipped out
and it's bigger in this room I'm in
right now and every shelf was full and
these they're like all these books are
already paid for we just have to get
them out so these cats are doing a
[__] killer business and it does your
heart good because it's comic books it's
the you know the [__] reason we even
do this [__] because we grew up reading
comic books and now they make movies and
TV shows and video games and [__] like
that
but it all started with the word and the
picture and there's still an audience
for it so I did a signing a caps can
which was lovely and then at night I did
a show at the Sanderson Center the first
q a I've done like a long time certainly
the first q a I've done straight up q
and I'd q a all the time like it's
modcastle after shows but a show that's
just a q a
first one I've done [__] without weed
it's now like been 20 weeks since I've
smoked weed
um
so it was it was a hell of an
interesting night and a great show
Branford was wonderful Canada is always
nice to me then I went back down to the
States to Jersey and me and Ralph did
Hollywood Babylon on Saturday night and
that was wonderful uh and then I got
back I saw my kid on Sunday she flew
into Jersey to start shooting a movie up
North so uh she came down to the theater
her and Austin her boyfriend and um it
was late at night it was like 10 o'clock
at night 11 o'clock at night and we she
I was like we're going to watch
guardians galaxy which he hasn't seen
and she comes in she was like you're
[__] showing The Little Mermaid and I
was like oh God no and uh that's what
she chose to watch instead so I've seen
Guardians you know twice three times now
uh I I had no intention of watching The
Little Mermaid but I'll be able to speak
knowledgeably about The Little Mermaid
watched all
tours and
[__]
the cartoon was under 90 if I remember
correctly I mean it was a quick hit fun
songs you know [__] good little moral
and
Hans Christian Anderson out for that
movie
they invented new [__] songs mark
he did
and what for two hours and 15 minutes
it's not like it wasn't well made but
Heavens we'll talk about that later and
then as of Monday I've been uh home here
man and uh the movers came on Monday my
house is now 90 empty as we prepare to
paint it for the inside for the first
time in 21 years uh getting ready to put
it up on the market so it's been a
[__] crazy 10 days
um and then I go out this weekend
to Dallas for Fan Expo
um in uh in the state of Texas you know
that Dallas as opposed to Dallas Ohio
yeah
but so it's been a it's been a whirlwind
trip man so I have not that's a long way
oh my God uh that's a long way of saying
that I have not returned to the my ring
just fell off to the uh
picket lines what's it like on the
picket lines you know it's uh it's
there's there's a good energy on the
Pagan line
um there's been some strike activity
some some some amptp via's Alliance of
Motion Picture television producers
um the way that the our our the unions
all have three-year contracts with the
amptp set Alliance but those the
contracts in the renegotiations contract
is a staggered Affair
um The Writer's Guild goes first in May
the Director's Guild goes second and the
Screen Actors Guild goes third and so
the writers
um if you have not been under Iraq uh it
did not go well it's a negotiation so
we're on strike and have been now this
is week six
um the Director's Guild
um went in for their negotiations and
struck a deal with the with the alliance
of Motion Picture television producers
that's right or the release a
preliminary deal has been met
um what now has to happen is the board
of directors of the DGA has to vote on
said deal
um which apparently they did and then
they're recommending it to the
membership now to vote
and then we'll see what happens
um the deal uh according to the DGA the
deal has made some historic gains in
certain places
um some less than historic gains in
other places but
um each of these gills will do
ultimately what is best for their Guild
um what they seem what they deem to be
best for the guild
um The Screen Actors Guild which is the
biggest of the three
um held what's called a strike
authorization vote which the WJ had done
beforehand which basically it pulls the
membership and asks them for permission
to go into negotiations with the ability
to Strike should it be required
um it's another you know it's another
bullet in the chamber of that particular
gun that is negotiating with the amptp
and a strong authorization vote is seen
as a pretty decent weapon or a tool to
help get what you want
um the Screen Actors Guild has never
done a strike authorization code before
but they did and they came back with of
these 60 000 members who voted
98. whatever percent
um authorized to vote which means that
they're serious now about going and
getting the things that they want that
means the constituency of the Screen
Actors Guild sag-aftra as well
um have said yeah strike if you gotta
right now the uppers can decide as they
go when's their negotiation I think it
starts this week it starts this week I
think it starts either today or tomorrow
and uh if the am
PTP
uh you know plays Hardball like they've
been playing with the writer's Guild
then sag has been authorized to strike
right you know now the the writers have
always been deemed a sort of the unruly
children of these three guilds
um the DGA has always been the uh the
the sort of the the Elder son I'm the
eldest boy says the DGA
um
and uh and the the actors it wasn't
but Kendall was not the eldest boy like
they all leave Connor out of it man he
was the oldest boy
he wasn't the eldest boy I saw that uh
um uh trending on Twitter and I thought
it was like oh finally condor's gonna
assert himself but instead it was
[__] Kendall
that unreasonable son of a [__] did you
see the story where Jesse Armstrong was
like so we're shooting that scene
and you know Jared what was his name
Jeremy Strong yeah
like ad-libs improvises getting up on
the railing
you know and like [__] thinking about
jumping into the Hudson and [__] like
and Jesse Armstrong was like not what I
had in mind for the character and more
importantly terrified us all because we
would have had frog men waiting in the
water and stuff like that uh mercifully
he didn't do it but we'll talk about
succession ending later on anyway back
to um real story of succession and and
the the actors have always been this
sort of wild card in that they rarely
strike they're the biggest Union
um but and we always have been seen as
like a bunch trying to hurt a bunch of
cats sometimes in the dark
um and so with an authorization vote it
seems as if both they are serious about
the issues that are facing their
constituency some of which overlap with
the directors and the writers some of
which are uniquely theirs
um but it has shifted the tenor I think
of the strike entirely which is oh could
we have a two union strike we've never
had a two union strike before and if the
actors walk then that really shuts down
the town because you know without
scripts it's hard without actors it's
impossible all right and so you know if
the actors do go on strike
um then I think that does bring a hasty
resolution to uh to what this this
action is
um you know and the hope is always that
you know whatever deal the directors
make
suddenly becomes a bit better for us we
get to improve upon their deal if the
actors go on strike then the studios
will be much more incentivized to sit
down and deal with everybody at once and
hopefully just wrap this thing up but so
there's there's some Joy de V there's a
Esprit de corps uh maybe some other
French words about the feeling on the
line in chat Mark we have a lot of
people who are telling you to fix your
camera because it's upside down but we
should probably point out
if you haven't seen yeah what the [__]
kids it's spider-verse man
it's miles morality that's why the
world's upside down behind Mark the
world's upside down behind me because
all of my shelves are [__] empty look
at this horrible [__] oh I quickly
cobbled together some [__] behind me so
it just wasn't a sea of
of whiteness like my office got
gentrified behind my back did you become
a Restoration Hardware
yes nice
um yeah man in this [__] I'm telling you
90 of our [__] is in storage which I'll
be honest with you I've missed anything
so it's like there must be some must the
whole thing must be a metaphor for
capitalism
it's just a reminder that you just don't
need that much [__] in life as much [__]
as you accumulate crazy the amount of
[__] that I never touched behind me or
throughout the rest of the house
um
all right so uh so writer's Guild strike
still in full effect folks indeed sag
mate joined the fight and uh as Mark
feels that that would
that would
just
end [__] however reality TV says hold my
beard indeed
we got some uh some wrestling In-laws in
case you want to look at that we got
some Housewives who are very real in
whatever City they live in you don't
need a writer for that and you don't
need an actor for that believe that
believe it or not those shows don't have
writers or actors
uh just a lot of drama somehow so we'll
keep you abreast kids of when
shits on and whatnot when shit's off but
until then check out Mark's feeds man
and his Instagram and you still [__]
with Twitter or no I have not [__]
with Twitter in a while it's been a like
I haven't I haven't closed up shop there
like I still have the handle but
um I I don't frequent that way too much
um I I think about it occasionally
returning
um especially with the strike especially
with you know being able to talk about
that stuff it was nice when promoting
new material
um as a as a as a way to signal boost
some things but uh but the day to day of
it I don't miss that much at all
uh reborn Hunter 3213 says he's curious
how wrestling gets around the writer
thing like they have staff writers what
a good question right
but I guess those writers aren't a part
of the writer's Guild that's my guess in
the same way that like video game
writers are not part of the guild and
animation is not part of it as well you
know their like animation has a couple
of like wiggle rooms where you can if if
you're a show runner with some Moxie you
can you can have a guild covered cartoon
which began with if I remember correctly
The Simpsons
um was the first like it was the fox
Primetime animation loophole and so the
Simpsons were the first Family Guy you
know and all of those like Fox
um evening shows are Guild covered some
Netflix cartoons are some you know Hulu
some of that stuff is but by and large
there's all separate animation Guild so
that's my guess my guess is that the the
WWE
um writers or aew or whatever wrestling
Foundation Federation you're a follower
of are not members of The Guild
um Josh mundoll is saying Kev what
happened to my fantastic two poster
um and he's asking also Excalibur June
17th that's my castle Cinemas
um
Josh you're fantastic too and we sell uh
you know before every screening that I'm
it's in attendance at that's my castle
centers my movie theater back in New
Jersey we do auctions so like you know
before Jersey girl we did auctions for
like
you could you could have won the uh the
crew jacket from rap of Jersey girl all
the actors got this jacket uh posters
signed by like Ben and and Liv Tyler and
Raquel and me when we did uh Babylon we
auctioned off stuff we did Jaws
everything that I do like for example
coming up not this week but next week
June 15th 16th and 17th
we're doing uh watch with Kev colon The
Flash so the opening weekend of the
Flash
you can come watch it that's my castle
Cinemas with me seven o'clock show
there's the artwork and
I mean it's the movie artwork we just
put my face on it and um then uh you
know afterwards I do a q a for a movie I
had nothing to do with it's such a blast
uh but it like in front of that we'll be
doing auctions every night one of the
auctions is a a Justice League Baseball
cap that has the entire [__] Justice
League signed it like yeah and gal and
Henry and so for everybody everybody
everybody
needs somebody uh we'll auction that off
auction off a bunch of cool [__] auction
off some shirts that I made for
Supergirl on the flash those auctions
are [__] fun man it's usually like
a whole hour before the show even begins
because we're auctioning [__] off
um so anyway Josh was asking about that
it's coming Captain uh
Ernie's in charge of that so I'll get on
Ernie smart Kessel keeper Ernie
O'Donnell also just while we're talking
about Spa Castle Cinemas so I turned 53
on August 2nd Mark
another year almost uh to celebrate on
July 29th which is the Saturday before
August 2nd we're doing uh a uh birthday
show at smodcast of Cinemas which is
very interesting we're going to do a
birthday q a show but I decided against
instead
we're doing a live script reading of
Superman lives throw that art up JC
Banff man let's show the kids what that
artwork looks like look at that
look at that
um that's gonna be July 29th that's my
castle Cinemas we're reading my script
aloud my 1997 Superman live script the
longest draft of it and that's how we're
going to celebrate my birthday but it's
a cosplay
birthday so you can come in costume as
your favorite character be who you want
to be while we sit up there and read the
[__] script man who's uh who's doing
the reading do you have uh do you have
fancy people
no
[__] it's me maybe I'll read all the
parts [__] you I'm fancy
I'm fancy I say who I say when
I say
um yeah I I don't know that I'm bringing
in fancy people and [__]
um you know I think you know what they
taught me at that [__] nut house that
I was at when I went to Tucson I'm
enough Mark I'm enough so don't be
[__] triggering McGee telling me that
I need people I'm the goodest boy I
choose me I validate myself
you choose me I choo choo choo uh
tickets for watch The Flash with Kev or
watch with Kev calling the flash or uh
the Superman lives uh birthday script
reading available right now that's
modcastlecinemas.com also July 1st we're
doing
um bear is driving the clerk's cartoon
marathon and Jeff Anderson and Brian
o'holleran Randall and Dante are going
to be in the hizzy uh so that's a good
ass time too we're always doing fun [__]
that's my castle Cinemas kids and there
have been so many people who are like I
I literally cannot get there from
England from [__] California from
Maryland I would disagree with the
Maryland part I mean it's just a drive
you know it's just a car right but
so many people is like can't you stream
this [__]
we're we're we're working on it right
now kids so if you can't make it to
these events live and in person we're
going to be doing a stream that you
could join up and and watch it along
with everybody else and stuff
so Dragon spawn Castle Cinemas into the
future I just this week man like months
ago I think back in like November
um we ordered this like Barco projector
which is a laser [__] projector
high-end [__] mark and it just got there
so we will have the best the best in
theater one the best [__] projection
picture in all of New Jersey like this
is this is the kind of projector that
you know they use at [__] the AMC up
in Manhattan you know yeah or or this or
the Alamo Drafthouse but I don't even
think Alamo Drafthouse as the one we got
um this [__] is high and bro if you're
like a nerd that's like I want Pitch
Perfect beautiful projection
you're gonna [__] come your pants
when you you come see a movie at my
[__] movie theater and [__] let me
hook my Apple TV up to it so I can sit
down there and use it like my television
as well
um but when I'm not using like my TV
because there's nothing to watch because
[__] The Whole World's on strike and
now succession's over God damn it
um we're gonna be showing movies I can't
wait to watch
spider-verse again
through this [__] projector because
our our previous projector was nice and
spider-verse looked Vivid and [__] but
oh my god with this Barco
Sun it might be worth flying all the way
to smodcast Castle just to watch that
but Mark is coming to smodcast Castle
yeah it's 25th we're doing Batman Beyond
Live
on August 25th just like we did it in
March and then August 26th we're doing a
double feature that Mark conceived of
called keep calm and Curry on a salute
to Tim Curry the first show is clue and
the second show is Legend two shows for
the price of one and then me and Mark
will get up in Q a for movies we had
nothing to do with nope
and look Batman's here he's probably
here to remind us that uh June 15th
is that what you nodding about yeah June
19th in California you didn't have any
[__] trust in me you didn't have any
faith I know how to sell JC don't
trigger me and send me back to the Nut
House me I'm a good boy
Nate myself but JC's right uh June 19th
me and Mark if you're like in Los
Angeles like all the cool [__] happens
in New Jersey which nobody ever said
ever
we are going to be doing
Batman Beyond live again just like we
did for the 400th episode right here in
Los Angeles in the city of angles
um June 19th Juneteenth if you will is
that correct no yes come and buy me
drinks for junetique that's right uh me
too
reparations
liquid reparations
uh June 19th tickets are on sale right
now now come in Banff man because now we
need information where do they get them
tickets uh
fatman619.eventbrite.com it's up on the
screen if you want to do that I'll put
it in the chat as well what an easy
address to remember
HTM we had a good ass time at the last
show live show that we did at uh that's
awesome I'm in villainy Cantina Banff
man wears many hats kids like today he's
wearing that hat right now but when he's
not doing this show facilitating this
show making sure that you can all see it
from the privacy of your own home
he's running the best damn Watering Hole
that is not [__] breaking any
copyright or trademark laws ever
right here in Hollywood Hollywood
Boulevard you've seen it on this show
come be at it on Juneteenth man June
19th when me and Mark do fat man beyond
that's the weekend after flash open so
I'll be in Jersey doing the 15th 16th
and 17th watch Flash with cap and then
we're going to talk about it at [__]
at scum and villainy cantina on the 19th
I'm on I'm by Coastal [__] I'm biased
[__] oh yeah bye bye Boys you've always
been I have been some people have been
asking me in chat they're like where are
you moving New York or New Jersey or L.A
the answer is both
um we'll be buying a house here in Los
Angeles when we eventually buy a house
but I have an apartment above smodcast
so I don't need to buy anything there I
just that's where I go stay when I'm on
the East Coast
so tickets everywhere if you're on the
East Coast if you're on the West Coast
you come see me and Mark uh either place
only in August for Mark but maybe you
can see me practically every [__]
weekend in New Jersey I mean maybe I'll
come back in October maybe I'll uh maybe
I'll come up with a funny reason to come
back to the theater in October
you should for The Hunt For Dead October
yeah a couple horror movies we can
program oh that is a good pun right
there do you think the strike will be
over by then I hope so
that'd be great
but I think so you're gonna have to
start making your living as a live
Entertainer my friend I know I'm gonna
need a road show we need like one of
them traveling vans that I can fill with
my tchotchkes to sell
that or just [__] do fat man beyond
we just go places and do the same show
live like we used to do we used to do
that a lot let's do it again where the
strike goes on and on that's like you
just build multiple [__] dates you go
out there in the world because I'll tell
you something a prophet is never
accepted in his hometown
here New Jersey people like ah we've
seen it we take this show to [__]
Kentucky we take the show to Nebraska we
take this show to [__] Ohio we live
like fat rats and Kings charge any price
we want a hundred dollars to meet some
quasi celebrities with the whiff of
entertainment about them foreign
I'm not sure if it was entertainment but
they talked for nine hours they did they
talked a long time mostly they bitched
about the strike
but we'll do it in your hometown kids
close to you never mind [__] you
streaming and watching it and [__] like
that be there in the room where it
happens as that coming to your house
songs yeah [__] you pay us enough
we'll literally come to your house and
stream there we should offer that man
they're crazy good people out there that
would just be like oh my God I'll pay
you guys 30 grand to stream the show
from my house done done I remember the
Foo Fighters I want to say it was like
10 years ago they did a thing called the
garage tour where they would just go
around the country and play in people's
garages
like they'd make you know they make
contact with people that like garage
bands like you know what the Foo
Fighters going to show up to your house
set up their gear in your garage and
play a concert for your friends
and I thought that was always fun so
again I will come to your living room
we'll watch a movie with you we'll talk
about it maybe we'll stream it from your
house it'll cost you a thousand dollars
an hour
I mean that's that's a little low for
having sex I mean I'm trying to make it
a bargain first
don't
don't don't we need the money we're
[__] out of work writers for Heavens
um before we dive into our show content
kids before we talk about Spider-Man
colon across the spider verse
um a movie that
um well we'll hold the thought
um perhaps we should uh bring up our
sponsor our first of two sponsors for
the evening man indeed the good folks
at Native who we absolutely love our
first sponsor of the evening putting us
in front of you
giving us the money that requires us is
required in order for us to stream this
into homes everywhere and stuff uh
Native folks uh give your skin the
protection it deserves with natives
mineral sunscreens go to nativedeo.com
Fatman follow along as we talk about
them uh or use the promo code Fatman at
checkout you're gonna get 20 off your
first order that's nativedeo.com Fatman
or use the promo code Fatman at checkout
nativedeo.com Fatman or promo code
Fatman now you know native
they're amazing uh they we they've been
a sponsor of ours for a while man they
make that the good smelling this [__]
and the good smelling this [__] you're
like what are they selling now man
sunscreen why because it's the summer
man I love the feeling of soaking up the
sun this time of year
that feels like a lie
I'm usually indoors all right let me
reword this okay sometimes I'm forced to
leave my house and I have to soak up the
sun this time of year or if you're a
striking writer like Mark Bernard and I
you're spending a lot of time under the
goddamn Sun lately
writers are in a dark pit with no lights
on doing this [__]
but now lately we're on lines holding up
picket signs and [__] uh with all that
time in the sun you're always worried
about protecting the skin right but with
Native sunscreen you can give skin the
protection it needs and as you soak up
some much-needed Sun take it away mark
it is quickly absorbing ultra sheer
hydrating and lightweight sunscreen
formula offers broad spectrum SPF 30
protection from both UVA and UVB rays
all Native sunscreen is made with a 20
active zinc oxide formula that is
dermatologist tested and suitable for
your sensitive skin we all have
sensitive skin kids particularly around
our taint so yes so if you're doing you
know face down ass up in the Sun
get yourself some of that native it's
summertime if you're not doing face down
ass up you're doing it wrong
well native sunscreen is made from oils
derived from plants that seal in skin
moisture and is vegan and cruelty free
you can choose from one of NATO's three
delicious but subtle scents like coconut
pineapple Rose or Sweet Peach and nectar
for your face and body and taint or try
to natives juice coconut and pineapple
yeah oh I'm a sweet peach for my sweet
peaches are you really yeah Peach has a
smell
sure does
it smells like Peach that's a very
strong smell coconut has a very strong
smell it smells like a [__] pina
colada I like to smell like a mixed
drink
so I'd like to smell like a Long Island
iced tea
booze and alcohol
um or native does have an unscented
option if you prove if you decide to let
your other scent take over you want your
natural Castle to creep through man then
you use that unscented option with all
Native sunscreens you're going to get
protection from the Sun that's free of
chemical laxatives
oxybenzone
octanoxate and avabenzone man which
makes native sunscreen compliant with
the Hawaii act 104 which was passed in
an effort to protect Hawaii's reefs man
come on don't [__] don't get in
trouble with Hawaii's 5-0 For Heaven's
Sake no Jason Momoa will come and kick
your [__] ass you will man if you
solve the fast x movie
like I didn't
[Music]
that movie did not do well at its mod
Castle I'll tell you that right now I
walked into the theater to open the door
there was literally nobody in the in the
four o'clock screening seven o'clock
screening one guy by himself I felt so
bad I went in I was like you're all
right buddy he's like this is the way I
like it it's fair enough and I [__]
off yeah it's like I bought the whole
theater out just for me I know dude
could have jerked off in the theater and
you know we only only way we would have
known is if he left a mess to clean up
there ain't gonna be no mess with Native
kids I'll tell you that right now give
your skin the protection it deserves the
natives mineral sunscreens go to
nativedeo.com Fatman or use the promo
code Fatman at checkout you're gonna get
20 off your first order you little [__]
yeah I said it
that's nativedeo.com Batman or use the
promo code Fatman at checkout one more
time for the people who are like what
did he say
nativedeo.com Fatman or use the promo
code fat man we love the folks the good
Folks at Native and they seemingly love
us either that they must have a big ad
spend that they gotta spread out but
they always tend to sponsor this show
and God damn it we appreciate it
particularly in these strike out on time
so we thank the good Folks at Native for
their constant support indeed and now
on with the countdown number 48
.
oh bam fans back everybody you touched
on something I've always wondered as a
theater owner if nobody buys a ticket do
you still show the movie to an empty
theater
what an interesting question from Banff
man uh why didn't you put that in Super
Chat and pass 200 then
I'll tell you right now I asked that
question fairly recently if smodcast
Will keeper Ernie O'Donnell
what happens if nobody comes he goes we
play the movie for the first 10 minutes
and then shut it off
so if you've ever asked like if if a
movie happens nobody comes did it happen
it happens for 10 minutes and then they
match it up and then if somebody's like
oh my God I couldn't find parking in
this one horse town I just I I I'm here
to see the [__] four o'clock show and
it's 4 10. guess what we do at spawn
Castle Cinemas we started from the
beginning for you really that's how we
roll at smart Castle Cinemas man because
we believe in the customer because
there's only like nine of them ever
and that doesn't [__] with the next show
that's supposed to run for nobody
there's always a bit of time built in
but that would require somebody to show
up for the next show
me right now man film Exhibition at
least in our theater I'm hoping that
Barco projector changes things but
you know no no complaints man I didn't
buy a movie theater to get rich I bought
a movie theater so I could do any
[__] thing I want and I I do all the
time we do [__] shows my shows are
always [__] fairly well attended and
packed I mean for Jaws we had like 120
530 people or something like that yeah
strong they could have watched that [__]
at home
could wash it on their [__] phone but
people like ooh I want to see it on the
big screen so guess what we're going to
do every year Jaws
um
Red State we had like 75 people show up
I watched all three movies that weekend
I sat in the back of my we got apple
boxes you know that you get on movie
sets and [__] like that
I sit in the back of my Apple box lean
against the back wall I watched the [__]
out of some Jaws I watched the [__] out
of some [__] Red State red State's a
goddamn good movie I know it's gross if
I say it because I'm the filmmaker but
[__] Michael Parks is Magic you know
we did too after
uh Hollywood Babylon uh Josh Roush made
a movie called long Lonesome Highway
about Michael Parks the late great
Michael Parks it was a Quentin favorite
and a Kevin Smith favorite as well what
a great documentary it was
um and he's about to get the interview
with Quentin that he hasn't had for all
this time
uh that's the kind of thing you could do
when you own a movie theater so I don't
give a [__] if people don't show up to
see fast decks
you know whatever [__] go ahead you
go to the car Mikey and watch it you go
to [__] AMC and watch it don't
support a mom and pop shop you little
jerk
I'll still be [__] putting asses in
seats with [__] Jersey Girl uncut and
Hollywood Babylon and I'm coming off
drunk aren't I mad at me a little a
little a little uh Orson Welles and
citizen game it's the Celsius man it's
it's grape it's like wine so I'm like
hey hey you it's like caffeinated wine
[Music]
um all right man so while I was at smart
Castle Cinemas guess what I watched tell
me what you watched Little Mermaid oh my
God yeah yes I did and look I ain't
saying it's not well made it's
incredibly well made in fact at one
point about 20 minutes into it when I
was like there's two hours left
um I was sitting there thinking like
it's crazy man they got uh what's her
name um
Melissa McCarthy McCarthy
like just slithering around the bottom
of the ocean floor as if she's really
doing that you know what I'm saying and
like and then there's a little girl
Helly Bear Barry Bailey Bailey Hallie
Bailey Haley Bailey is that her name
Holly Bailey oh Holly Haley Bailey be a
lot cuter Polly Ollie Bailey
she's [__] jetting around under the
sea
trademark and like moving and swimming
fast and I'm taking it for granted like
she's one of them weeky-watchy mermaids
and [__] with the fake tail but all this
[__] had to be put together right like
they're all wearing green and dots all
over their faces and then they [__]
put it it was crazy man the amount of
craftsmanship that goes into the that
[__] [__] and it's seamless like I
was like Wow Melissa McCarthy looks like
a giant octopus woman who's moving
around
you know in real time uh is even though
I work in the movie business sometimes I
forget that a lot of [__] is like
trickery this movie looked absolutely
[__] phenomenal Rob Marshall directed
it uh
you know and he did Chicago right yeah
[__] I love Chicago so even if even if
Little Mermaid you know sucked I would
I'd still give him [__] credit for
doing Chicago but it didn't suck it was
well made it didn't need to be two hours
and 15 minutes long I'll tell you that
much right now no and I also think that
like like I saw it and had an emotional
response to it
separated from the movie itself
um because you know I I if you're gonna
make it two and a half hours to 15
whatever it was then like hey you know
it'd be great why is Ursula so awful
like what's her story what's her deal
does it just need to be like oh I want I
want what my brother has I want why does
she have such a mad on for Ariel why why
is she the way she is also were they
related in the cartoon
I don't remember I don't that hit me I
bumped into that a little bit when she
was like my brother I was like wait that
I think that's new yeah but like give me
that motivation give me a new Ursula
song that explains why she is why she is
how she is
um instead they gave Prince Eric a
[__] song yeah who did not need it
lovely dude you know in terms of the guy
who played him God Bless but like
[__] I don't need to hear that guy
sing no um not not the actor the [__]
character it's like he gives a [__]
what's on his mind especially because
he's not singing to anybody like he's
just walking along the beach just like
belting a number and it's like well if
it's not going to be too aerial if it's
not going to be to her his mother if
it's not going to be to a person then I
don't need Eric's I want song it's just
being like I Wanna [__] a fish
why can't I [__] a fish just naming all
the fishes he loves he wishes he could
[__] like that I certainly Wanna [__] a
blowfish
[Music]
um you know and then and then I I didn't
understand I mean hey there's always a
weirdness about that story that like oh
right you need to steal the woman's
voice you need to steal her agency her
ability to communicate in order for her
to fall in love like there's the weird
the the lack of agency of Ariel is
somewhat astonishing in that story and
some of it you just can't get away from
because it's there
um and then the end of The Movie Spoiler
in case you've never seen a little
mermaid
um her father King Triton at the end
after hating All Humans comes around and
decides maybe humans aren't so bad
you know Flash Forward another couple
hundred years and yeah humans are the
worst
um but he has to make this choice about
saying well I just I'll never see you
again because now you're going to live
in man's world it's like broke
she could also come and visit like you
could give her the power to have her
tail and then have legs at will she
could be a Transformer if you need her
to be she's got a magic [__] Fork
he's gonna do anything with the Trident
man just makes you really can't he does
he does it's weird the Trident blow [__]
up
or [__] gives people legs
it's really ill-defined man
go to the store and buy a tribe what
does this one do well sir you'll love
this feature yeah basically they'll do
different [__] this one blows [__] up or
gives people legs he's like oh man I was
looking for one that would I was looking
for a salad fork he's like well we got
one of those too but it blows the salad
up yeah
um the uh you know my kid
was like oh my God I want to watch The
Little Mermaid and I was like oh my God
like are you kidding me we could watch
[__] Guardians we can watch across
the spider-verse but like
I was reduced you know almost like my
kid was not 23 but in fact three or four
and she was like I want to watch The
Little Mermaid and just like I did back
in the day look look you know I I saw
the little mermaid when I had no
children and no wife and I [__]
lugged that [__] up you know what [__]
you I love The Little Mermaid the
cartoon
um is amazing and you know [__] is a
makes you tear up the old one is when I
saw it when I was a in my late teens
early 20s it made me emotional and [__]
but you know life goes on and [__]
the idea of sitting there watching the
live action remake this was my first
live action Disney remake I did not see
Jungle Book I did not The Lion King I
did not see Beauty and the Beast I my
guess years ago
was once they bought Pixar they were
gonna remake all their old classic
cartoons but in Pixar format like
3D yeah which would have I would have
been I would honestly I would have been
more into that personally but who what
do I [__] know because they print
money with these live action versions
and [__] where it's like hey man
remember that cartoon this is what it
would look like if real people were
doing it
and people love it now you know I ain't
saying Disney's dumb they're smart as
[__] because they get a second bite at
the IP Apple all new and they don't have
to pay anyone who was in the old one and
[__] like that you know cost some pretty
penny to do it but it seems like they're
reaping all the benefits although you
know if I can I've read an article about
how uh overseas they're like we don't we
don't want this you know and there could
be some
some racist Edge to all that yeah yeah
because of course there was always going
to be it was it was part of the like
we're not gonna put John boyega on the
poster for these Star Wars movies
because you know turns out that maybe
China and South Korea don't feel the
same way about black people as
some of the rest of the world do what's
that all about
I mean hey Mark figure out racism on the
show explain to me racism and also
International races
like I'm pretty sure you got a handle on
America's racism
you seem to know a lot of [__] you know
a lot about the writers strike well why
are people racist Mark yeah do you have
a hot five on racism
let me tell you something [__] that
little girl Holly Bailey yeah
[__] incredible incredible voice
wonderful performance
I bought that she was a [__] Mermaid
um but more than that like that singing
was off the charts [__] impressive
that must have been like why they
chiefly hired it like listen to that
[__] voice like she don't need like
the her dad's magic Fork to have a voice
that beautiful she's just a real ass
person with a voice that beautiful so
it's tough not to get emotional when
she's singing like [__]
part of that world you know [__] she
brings it out of here even though I've
heard that song a zillion [__] times
she sang it and I was like Jesus I I do
want to be I wish I was a fish who
wanted to be a human being and I'm a
human being like I got there I'm at the
Finish Line I got exactly what you want
and yet you're singing so beautiful it
made me want more yes being that thing
that I am let me tell you about legged
privilege
believe me when she was singing I was
like kid it ain't that great on the land
trust me I'm sorry it's awful up here
yeah I mean down there what sharks
that's your biggest [__] fear like up
here home invasion two-word home
invasion yeah just don't go where the
sharks are it's fine a shark scene look
Wicked too it was incredibly well made
um did I need to see this no did I see
it because
you know I still love my kid and I was
reduced to uh of you know [__]
suddenly I'm looking at this 23 year old
and I see the little girl that I would
take to the movies all the time yes
absolutely so I'm glad I did it but you
know
two hours and 15 minutes at midnight
that's when we started watching this
[__] 11 o'clock actually more than 11.
and it was you know
oh yeah [__] they're still underwater
um but it was a beautiful experience and
the movie looks great and if you're into
that sort of thing by all means go see
it and stuff but it was not the best
movie I saw that weekend that's
absolutely I saw this weekend the past
weekend and perhaps the best movie I saw
all year
thus far
um and I don't know if you count this
[__] as a movie because you're like you
feel like a good tune but [__]
anything that evokes the power of
Storytelling and [__] emotion that
this movie evoked
has to be [__] Cinema with apologies
to Mr Martin's Scorsese
was Spider-Man across the spider-verse I
saw this movie one and a half times I
loved it so [__] much oh my God it
was you know this was the thought that I
[__] had
we are all nerds now like this is
something that only you and I
[__] 15 years ago maybe even 10 years
ago would have been able to completely
parse and understand but this movie is
so well made and we they've all these
[__] storytellers have been pillaging
comic book material now for a decade or
more
have trained the average moviegoer in
the language a secret language that
people like us only used to speak
amongst our nerdy selves and whatnot
that you can make a movie that deals
with the Multiverse and has a zillion
different Spider-Man in it and everyone
gets the concept nobody bumps into it at
all it's [__] commonplace for them
this played like a graphic novel come to
light and all I could think was that
quote from the from the The Incredibles
when syndrome is like you know when
everyone's super then no one will be
when all of us are nerds then no one
will be and that's where we are right
now because anybody can understand these
Concepts that heretofore maybe a decade
back would have been rarified breathing
for people that grew up reading this
[__] and cataloging these stories and
characters in their minds what used to
be the edge what used to be he you know
[__] for the few is now for the many
and I'm [__] here for it I know some
people get threatened by that where
they're like oh man it was cooler when I
liked it nobody else did I don't have a
garage band mentality the more the
[__] merrier and as I sat there
watching this movie we had on Sunday
night you know I tell you we don't get a
lot of people coming to the movies
Sunday night we had was it Sunday night
or Monday night we had like 46 people at
our night show which is like [__]
unheard of and [__] so the movie's doing
very well at our theater
um and not a single one of them got up
and left because they're like what I
don't get it why are there so many
Spiderman
everyone [__] understood this thing
from start to finish and it's quality
[__] storytelling do you know how
hard it is to follow up uh Spider-Man
into the spider-verse an incredibly
original story well told by Lord and
Miller like I'll be honest with you
going into this I was like there's no
way I could touch the original
it not only touches the original there
are times where I'm like did this
surpass the original
I loved it so [__] much
um they went deep on the parents this
time which I guess know your audience
right like [__] the kids coming
anyway so they're like let's give the
parents something to go on so his mom
and dad get way more screen time than
they did even in the first one and and
uh Spider Gwen gets [__] almost equal
billing in terms she opens the movie
like the first 20 minutes her spider
went in a really beautiful way
um but this is truly a Miles Morales
story and once again proves the insane
viability of this character and they and
the you know I know the spoilers thing
is up but I don't want to spoil too hard
but the reason you know in the trailers
if you haven't seen it yet they she they
see all the spider men and women are
chasing [__] Miles Morales and stuff
and I remember watching the trailers and
being like I wonder what that's about
why the reason they came up for why
you know he's a threat why the bad guys
essentially are all the [__]
Spider-Man yeah yes the spot is in it
and he's ultimately the big bad but
really it's Spider-Man versus Spider-Man
and women and the reason they came up
for it I thought was nothing short of
[__] brilliant I was like
never in a million years if they gave me
if they were like Kevin we want you to
do the sequel I wouldn't come up with
anything nearly as [__] good like it
was fantastic from beginning to end and
Visually [__] vibrant this is the
best looking animated film I think I've
ever seen in my entire [__] life it's
a work of art they should hang it up in
the Guggenheim
look at
I hope to God they give a lot of credit
to bills and Kevin because when I watch
these both the first one and this one I
see so much [__] bills and kevich
work in there particularly Daredevil
like love and debt
um
uh you know last time we had Kingpin as
a [__] as an incredible big bad this
time we have the spot
who starts off kind of goofy and then
becomes like so goofy that like his
secret origin is he's the guy that
[__] miles hits with a bagel
I thought that was hysterical he's like
you hit me with a bagel I was like he's
the bagel guy
but they start him off as as you know he
gets put down as villain of the week and
[__] and they build him up into
something [__] horrible but with good
reason where it makes sense where you're
like you know what man [__] like I
could see that I mean not like I could
see that happening in the real world but
they bring the collider back and that
makes a lot of sense all of it [__]
tracks and makes sense and [__] works
and Oscar Isaacs is [__] phenomenal
as little as he is in the movie they
make it seem like he's never into the
movie but he might as well be for the
time he's in it because he owns the
[__] screen
um doing Miguel uh Spider brand 2099
like I remember when they put him at the
tail end of into the spider-verse and I
was like oh that's cute they made him
[__] a insanely wonderful viable
[__] character
um man oh god oh I love this movie so
much and I look forward to watching it
again now that we're putting that Barco
projector in I'm gonna watch it in
[__] pristine laser projection at my
own goddamn theater smodcast Castle
Cinemas in Atlantic Highlands New Jersey
um I I loved it top to bottom start to
finish best movie of the year so far for
me now I ain't seen the flash yet and
I'll be honest with you even if the
flash sucks as long as they got Michael
Keaton in the Batman suit
but this movie was absolutely phenomenal
I did not know how they were gonna
[__] stick The Landing after the
first one which was incredible and won
an Academy Award they stand a great
chance at repeating that and there's
gonna be a third part so it could be a
[__] three-peat [__] Lord and
Miller could win three Oscars for in for
the spider-verse movies and I for one
would be there for it I loved it so
[__] much man over to you
um I I if you if you're like an A plus
on it I'm kind of a b-plus on it
in that like I'm always here for Miles
Morales I'm always here for his parents
there's moments of that movie that hit
me you know like as a as a dad who has a
kid who just came back from his freshman
year of college you know when when Rio
has a conversation with Miles about like
when you go off into that world like you
could meet a lot of people like it's
it's the like remember who you are don't
forget where you came from you know I
hope you can love that little boy as he
becomes a man as much as I do and take
care of him like all that stuff was just
you know tear jerky just wiping my face
the entire time I'm watching that movie
um I think that like the design work the
animation is glorious and wonderful I
think spider Punk is this phenomenal new
addition that like I never read those
books like you know my my deep was that
real was that does that does he come
from a spider I'm not even sure if he
does like that's that's the that's how
much I don't know about
um where they've taken the Miles Morales
story in the comics and how deep they've
gone with that stuff but Daniel kaluya
as the the non-conforming anarchist
Spider-Man was just [__] awesome
every bit of that was great and even
looking at you know as I was watching
some deep dive on Tick Tock about it
even in the animation Styles where
um all of the other Spider-Man are
animated on the ones which means that
every frame you have a new pose in the
frame it makes it very fluid miles is
animated on the twos which means that
there's two frames before miles changes
pose that signifies that he's out of
step with the other Spider-Man it makes
him a little bit more Jagged a little
bit more stuttery a little bit more
comic Booky and spider Punk is on the
threes like he's out of step with
everybody because he won't conform to
either you know the fluidity or the the
weird Herky jerky and like I thought
that stuff was great my my my soul
issues with the movie like I have two
two of them and one is that spot isn't a
great bad guy
um only because even miles doesn't
consider him his villain and he doesn't
really he impacts the larger plot he
doesn't at all affect miles's story he
feels like he's a plot device more than
he's a villain for for Spider-Man
whereas Miguel is a hundred percent a
villain for Spider-Man like the idea
that you know inward like light spoilers
but not beef spoilers but the idea that
for Miguel
keeping the order of the Multiverse is
the prime directive for him
and Miles himself is an aberration in
the Multiverse miles signifies
everything that that Miguel is the
original the original anomaly he said
yeah like you know the spider that was
supposed to go
um to a different Universe gets shunted
into miles's universe and bites him
which means that there's a universe
without a Spider-Man that's not supposed
to not have a Spider-Man and so the idea
is the blamed miles for the death of
that universe is Spider-Man yeah like he
doesn't die unless the Chris Pine
Spiderman right who was a great
Spider-Man by all lights and was the
protector of that particular New York
and so that idea that that Canon is
inviolable you know there is something
incredibly subversive about that idea
you know the the die-hard fan who
doesn't Brook any deviations from Canon
as opposed to the people who like hey
man just give me the one that's cool you
know and that's that's the The Dilemma
of the movie and I just felt so much
more deeply about miles and Miguel's
than I did about the spot
um but I also think that like there's
there's an emotional disconnect for me
in the first half of the movie seems to
be about miles's story with his parents
which are you didn't show up on time
you're always late you know we we don't
want you to leave home we don't want you
to go to Princeton we don't want you to
stray we want to keep you close but we
also want you to remember who you are to
the end of the movie which is your
mistake miles like you never should have
happened you never should have been a
Spider-Man your your presence has
destroyed a part of the Multiverse and
we've got to fix it like those two
things aren't necessarily in line with
each other and so I just kind of I was
hoping that there would be an emotional
consistency there and for the first half
of the movie miles doesn't really have a
plot like he's just chasing Gwen around
like he's lonely and sad and then Gwen
shows up he's following Gwen and by
following Gwen he ends up in this in in
danger he ends up in mumbatin the Indian
version of Manhattan which is he was
delightful too and he's great is the guy
from Deadpool right yeah yeah it was fun
absolutely [__] lovely I was a
wonderful addition and is that also a
real Spider-Man there's a lot of people
in chat who said spider Punk is in
comics Dan slot co-created the character
so I'm imagining that the Spider-Man
from from mumbatin is also straight out
the comic books yeah I mean none of them
would surprise me and it's so well done
um like there's never a minute where I'm
watching that movie that I had a bad
time in it you know it's always
enjoyable it's always vibrant I mean I
think that like the way that they're
pushing art in these movies is so
remarkable like all the Gwen Stacy stuff
and like these weird bleeding pastels
and it is just all emotional tone
they're not even aiming for realism like
realism is the least thing they're
concerned about in the Gwen Stacy stuff
it's all the relationship between her
and her band and her and herself and her
and her dad you know was all incredibly
just well drawn and well well realized I
just I just kind of like there's there's
a nudge more that I was hoping for and
the emotional story and and in giving
miles a bit more to do when he's on
screen
um but those are I'm not gonna say
they're small quibbles but like I still
had a blast at this movie I just it for
me is not as as resonant and emotional a
movie as the first one is and that's
hard to do the into the spider-verse is
maybe the best superhero movie I've ever
seen you know easy top three you know so
to not achieve those Heights I don't
blame a movie for not being able to
Jesus those sites are impossible to
achieve the what's up danger scene
there's nothing in this movie that's as
emotional as that is in that movie
you know the what's up dangerous scene
is this perfect encapsulation of of what
it means to become a hero what it means
to synthesize all those versions of
yourself the kid who's not sure of
himself the kid who's not sure his dad's
gonna like him the kid who's not sure
that the spider people are going like
him he's not sure he can do the thing
but believes he can and it's still a
little bit of afraid that he can't but
jumps off the building anyway like that
scene is just you know it's it's perfect
and there is no scene like that in
across the spider verse maybe they
didn't try for it maybe they realize
yeah we can't do that again let's try
something else
um so I can't even hold it against the
movie for not being able to achieve
Perfection twice because that's that's a
that's an incredibly long order did you
bump into it being a cliffhanger
um I bumped into it being a cliffhanger
only because it doesn't really cliffhang
the way like Empire Cliff hands Empire
Cliff hangs on tragedy right like this
cliffhangs on plot
not emotion explain you know Empire
Cliff hangs on oh my God my father is
the villain that we that we've been
fighting this whole time I lost my hand
I lost my friend like the the rebels are
on their last [__] legs like oh [__]
I don't know if they're gonna come back
from this whereas this like miles hasn't
lost anything yet
you know his dad is still his dad and
still alive Gwen's dad is still a
captain all the captains that we've been
told we should be afraid we're going to
lose we haven't lost yet
you know Miguel hasn't done the awful
thing yet spot hasn't done the awful
thing yet so miles is just lost which is
bad but it's not apocalyptically bad and
that's kind of what I was hoping for
something like holy [__] what's he gonna
do now and like we kind of know what
he's going to do after this Cliffhanger
that question isn't necessarily
unresolved but it just it didn't
like it didn't bother me that they
cliffhung I just wish it was a little
bit more perilous the cliff we were
hanging off of I had I've had a distant
memory of the fact that they were like
oh it's going to be two parts yeah
that I completely forgot right up until
to be continued I was sitting there
going like wow man how they're going to
get out of this now like this works
close to the Bone and [__] and there was
no what's up danger moment which means
that could probably happen in part three
if it was a movie Split in Two right it
totally could you know and like it's not
an origin story anymore and so that's
very much An Origin moment it's the oh
now you're Spider-Man this is the moment
you become Spiderman this is the moment
you become the hero that you're going to
be
um and like yeah they could have they
could have teed up an audience a bit
better that it's a cliffhanger because
yeah there were a couple of people in
the theater that I was in who were like
what the [__]
yeah just like out loud didn't know
you D and chat just said the crowd
moaned at my theater like when it ended
like oh
I was okay with it man I said look as a
theater owner I was like yes bring them
back bring them back in a few months
please I need the help this is the new
Super Mario Brothers
um you didn't find it emotional that his
uncle Aaron was alive
I mean
you know world yeah I mean I I did but
it's that is not necessarily the answer
to the question that have been posed
about miles in the the rest of the story
leading up to it
um it's an interesting twist I mean it's
a Twilight Zone episode right like he
ends up in this new world where he's the
villain and his dad is dead but his
uncle's alive and like which one would
have rather had like
but we know that he'd rather his dad
back we'd know he'd like to have his
uncle back too we know that you know
it's if the if the movie had been
you don't understand me dad the way
uncle Aaron understood me you know Uncle
Aaron knew who I was and accepted me for
who I was but you dad keep wanting to
force me to be a version of you
and so at the end of that to discover
like oh [__] my dad is dead but Aaron is
here and Aaron this Aaron might
understand me
and oh but wait this Aaron is evil again
and oh wait my dad is dead like it it
then inverts the question that he'd been
asking for the movie
um but like again I I deeply liked this
movie like I kind of adored it
um these are in no way like you know
to world ending knocks for me like you
know what [__] it this movie is awful
because these two things I didn't like
there's so much about this movie to love
there's so much about this movie I mean
Haley Steinfeld is Gwen Stacy is doing
amazing work I mean shamik Moore as
miles continues to do amazing work you
know all of that stuff with I mean his
parents and even just a little throwaway
[__] gags
of like when you know
when the the guidance counselor played
by Rachel Dratch it's like it's a great
American story she's like oh it's a
great immigrant story she's like from
Puerto Rico which is part of America
we're like Dominican and his mother's
snap her mother snaps his fingers and
the snap is the colors of the Puerto
Rican flag
I was like it's just it's the bagel [__]
it's just these little like things that
they tossed in there to make it
you know deep and layered in texture
it's it's yeah no it's it's done with
such care
and such love that I can't ever
okay Blix did chat says the universe 42
spider was supposed to bite the
alternate Fowler miles
yeah maybe because I think they did say
like Earth 42 or some says [__] that's
why he goes to the wrong universe is
because
that's that's what the go home machine
keys off of yes is that 42. that meant
that that spider was supposed to buy
that Miles and instead that Miles
becomes a Prowler
yeah or or that spider was about
supposed to bite that Peter Parker we
don't know that part of it either
um
but likely am nearly and chat says
reminds me of Dune a good film that
truly depends on the rest of the story
to be great would you back that
um that's that's a pretty good read you
know like it it doesn't have any
resolution in it
um you know like there's there's a
version of that story where where Miles
deals with the spot
and then reveals Miguel as the big bad
going into three you know at least I
would have some feeling of like oh he
did the thing like oh [__] no it's even
worse than you thought
um but yeah this does feel like it's
gonna need the other half to make it to
tell us the whole story Salvatore said
it was a hundred percent in the movie
that the 42 spider was supposed to bite
alt miles I don't remember that because
I do remember them saying something
about I thought he said something but no
he said they were talking about the
Peter Parker
from Miles world right because he'd be
in order for him right like he died
saving Miles because miles was there
like if you were never there then that
Peter doesn't die and Remains the
Spider-Man of your Earth
is that true
um yeah because I mean I'd have to watch
into survivorous again but I think it's
because that Peter Parker the Chris Pine
Peter Parker saves miles and by Saving
miles he exposes himself to getting the
[__] kicked out of him by um
and he got like a spider sense
[Music]
I mean if that's the case then [__]
hats off to Lord and Miller for like
there's no way when they were writing
that movie they knew they were going to
do a [__] sequel yeah that means they
had to go back into their own [__]
mythology and find these [__] moments
on which to build an entire new
mythology these cats man are versatile
as [__] versatile as [__]
um
God I love that [__] movie
somebody else wrote
um
why did they change miles dad's name did
you notice that
um in the comics his name was Jefferson
Davis
um and was married to Rio Morales and I
guess she gave miles her last name his
last name whatever
um and then in this one yeah his name is
now Jefferson Morales
um and I don't know why they changed it
I don't know if there's some other story
to be told there
um I mean it was always a thing that
that I sort of wondered because it was
like oh is Miles adopted or is or is is
Miles not Jefferson Davis's son like was
Miles Morales Rio's son with another guy
and miles is the adopted and Jeff is the
adopted father but like it seems as if
maybe they don't want to leave that kind
of ambiguity
in it anymore and so maybe they just
sort of they retconned it
um in the chat we got a back and forth
here John James Rave says it's a blink
and you miss it when it shows spider 42
in its Universe creeping up on a miles
with braids and then delusional Patriots
fan said no the 42 spider was supposed
to buy 42 Peter then Nicholas malillo
says in the scene where spot is telling
his origin with the spider you can see
the spider next to Miles 42 miles and
then the spider gets sucked into the
wormhole
I mean how many [__] how closely did
these people watch that [__] movie
what do you got a copy on home video
like how did you see that I mean given
how much visual information this movie
throws at you it's impossible like
there's one moment where I look forward
to being able to pause the movie in the
future
because when he's like first in the
lobby of you know [__]
the Hall of spiders or whatever the [__]
on uh new Manhattan or what is it called
Nueva York
they bang up all the names of the
various [__] Spider-Man and it's
going so fast and that's so distant you
can't [__] read them all but to see
this information
what you got you guys must have been
bitten by [__] radioactive spiders
yourself to be able to catch that man
uh Brett Flint says Jefferson didn't
want him to have his father's last name
because Jefferson Davis says yes a
confederate general
uh
Aleister Campbell says watch Lord and
Miller's the Mitchells versus the
machines excellent animation and a great
story and a really good film did you see
that I did it is wonderful
it is wonderful it's it's very much you
know in in the same regards of me being
in my emotions about having a kid
um who's beginning to leave the nest
Mitchells versus the machines is about a
family taking their daughter to drop her
off at college for the first time
and I watched that while with my son
while on tours of colleges with him and
so I'm sitting there like crying in my
Hyatt pillow while my son's like that
was fun right that was great so much
you're right Dad I'm fine
also points out that if miles name was
Miles Davis well
yes
also super cool but
um and then some people are trying to
dim the the light of others by saying
like all this trivia it's a Salvatore
says it's already all on Tick Tock and
Reddit basically Brittany Nicole said a
lot of it's from IMDb trivia but yeah
but somebody has to see this [__] first
yeah and this movie literally just came
out I watched it one and a half times
and I couldn't have told you about that
spider moment there's so much visual
information
being thrown at you every second of this
film like that would be really tough for
me to pick up yeah I mean
and it's also like I'm probably too old
to be that granular with a movie like
this anymore
um and that's fine like you know what
kids have fun with your finding the
tiniest of Easter eggs tell me about it
at the afternoon
I don't think understood us he goes it's
on Netflix Kevin yeah Mitchell versus
the machines yes no oh I thought he
meant [__] spider verse I was like no
it's not yeah
it's on uh I will check it out well
thank you Aleister Campbell and thank
you Mark for explaining that that's
about to go hard on Aleister Campbell
tell me it's on Netflix don't be helpful
how dare you uh how adorable was like
when they they were showing like the
captured [__] anomalies and [__] like
these are some video games and they had
the Green Goblin from the [__] like
Atari Superman game like the eight bit
Yeah and how awesome was it to see uh
[__]
they basically like uh visually
referenced
uh Toby Maguire and Andrew Garfield and
they visually referenced Andrew Garfield
and they referenced
Tom Holland by way of Donald Glover and
the prowler and as well as that
reference that Miguel makes about doctor
strange and that little nerd from Earth
blah blah blah blah so that you got to
imagine that they're saving Tom Holland
for the next one
I mean
it would be amazing if they did if they
didn't that's an amazing part if they
were like ah [__] them like of course
he's going to be there I mean they got
to save something for the [__] third
one yeah
um all that [__] that nerdy [__] was
[__] phenomenal and so deep Cuts I
tell you man honestly like I sat there
watching that movie going like why do I
do what I do like I suck I used to think
I was a writer I couldn't write this
[__] to save my life but you made me
feel better by being like it ain't all
that
I mean it's good but it's still got some
bumps bro I don't know if anybody ever
realized this but my God all you have to
do is say Spider-Man in a movie I'm like
Mark it's brilliant give it an Oscar
that's why this Flash movie is going to
make my [__] 50s man
Michael Keaton as Batman what
what you're talking about Superman he's
gone so there's a guy named Superman who
could stop Zod and they're like yeah and
he's like and he flies and he shoots
lasers out of his eyes and he goes he
flies and shoots lasers out of his eyes
and he goes and nobody thought to say
hey superman that's a little on the nose
and then he's like well you call
yourself Batman he goes yeah I don't
call myself Super Batman
I'm [__] there for it I saw somebody
on Twitter and be like this is stupid
[__] you that's fantastic somebody on
Twitter go like give a review of the
movie saying like this movie is so like
self-sufferential and [__] dick sucky
on the DC Universe in their own past
movies good
yes that's what I want
[__] yeah I want Spider-Man no way home
for the DC Universe and I'm gonna get it
I'm gonna get it I look at the trailers
and the little [__] spots for [__]
Flash and I'm like I wouldn't even think
to do this [__] this shit's so [__]
nerdy and clever
is beyond my capabilities and I always
thought I was nerdy and clever but I'm
[__] I'm about to be 53. so I'm an
old man all I can do is [__] I can
self-reference Kevin Smith boy you want
me somebody to be clever about Kevin
Smith movies I'm your guy but [__] I
couldn't do what these cats are doing
man this is next level [__]
storytelling
um and you know if some people are like
well that's not real writing just
referencing things that happened before
writing is referencing things that
happen
literally but you know this is just
referencing some very specific [__] and
if you're [__] Jam is that very
specific [__] like Michael Keaton in
Batman
like [__] Spider-Man like [__]
like by throwing up that 8-bit Green
Goblin in a little jail cell I was like
this is this is [__] crazy crazy
wonderful God bless these [__] I
don't know if there is a God mark But if
there is I hope he [__] takes Lord
and Miller straight to heaven Body and
Soul like they did blessed mother like
[__] they don't get to rot in the
ground these [__] should be canonized
for telling [__] comic like truly
geeky comic book worthy stories we're a
mass audience like you know they've been
doing this [__] for years now taking
comic book stories and selling them to
the mass audience but this [__] is so
deep cuts and nooks and [__] crannies
I didn't even know there was a spider
pump and these [__] are like making
it not only bringing it in but making it
work in a way where I'm like out if I
miss Spider Punk all this time
the original to live unto me spider Punk
material I gotta tell you man I'm like
[__] like this makes me happy I've lived
this long and in this universe if I was
sucked out of [__] Universe 42 good
because [__] What's Happening Here is
A-Okay with me I know we've had some
[__] you know shitty years recently
and [__] the world's falling apart
and [__] things are horrible but my
God the storytelling is really [__]
shifted into a place where I'm satisfied
and I live in this world so what do I
give a [__] about the real world I just
stay out of it and [__] [__] the real
world I live [__] the universe I'm
living in the spider-verse I'm living in
the back first I know it's a Flash movie
but let's be honest it's Michael Keith
Batman movie
I do think it's possible and I don't
think anybody's ever done this before
that each of these three movies could
win the best Oscar in its category
um in that best animated feature is the
Oscar that these movies are with the
first one wanted this one could win it
the third one can win it and I don't
think a Trilogy has ever pulled that
feat before
um maybe with the exception of like the
Toy Story movies
might have hit like one and two and
three won the best feature
um in this year
um but like The Godfather movies haven't
all won best picture you know like the
the best movies ever made you know that
as a series have never each of them
gotten that highest honor and look let's
be honest man let's put it on Front
Street and [__] there is no such thing
as a best picture there is no such thing
as the greatest movie ever made every
movie is the greatest movie ever made to
somebody
like don't matter what it is could be
Juwanna Mann that is somebody's favorite
[__] movie
above or not and [__] and and maybe
even save their life so there is across
the [__] Multiverse every movie that
gets made is somebody's [__] favorite
movie and stuff so whenever they're like
this is the best and the gold standard
you know
whatever because at the end of the day
as a guy who's made movies that nobody
likes I gotta believe I have to believe
Mark that every movie is somebody's
favorite movie and that's [__] true
so I you know in the age of social media
what's been very disheartening is to
find out how many people don't like
something that I love so much and and
believe must be universally beloved but
at the same time I don't pin my [__]
personality on it so if some
[__] wants to be like
spider-verse blows I'm like
I get it it ain't for you you're missing
out on some [__] magic because it is
for me you know it's just like they told
me when I was at [__] The Nut House
when I was in Sierra Tucson
and I was talking about
um you know being in a line of work
where it's like some people [__] love
you and some people hate you and hate
what you make and [__] like that and
I've spent like an inordinate amount of
time over the last 30 years
trying to get the people who don't like
me to like me to see my stuff a
different way to validate me whatever
the [__]
and Kelly Parks who is my trauma
therapist she goes
she goes what's your favorite ice cream
and I was like uh Oatley makes this
chocolate this oat milk chocolate ice
cream which is [__] amazing and that
was the base of the peanut butter shake
that I had from [__] plant power was
that Oakley [__] [__] Oatley vanilla
and then they put peanut butter I said
but that only chocolate [__]
like I'll eat it all [__] day
like it's beautiful well you know for
those that don't know I'm a vegan I
ain't trying to convince you so get off
my dick but like I don't have access to
the full world of ice cream anymore
because I got a heart condition that's
why I went vegan not because I'm [__]
woke or whatever [__] but I want to wake
every morning and so I [__] went
vegan so I said this oatly chocolate is
my favorite and she goes okay she goes
what's your least favorite ice cream in
the world and without hesitation Mark I
was like oh [__] rum raisin [__] it
[__] it to death who puts raisins in ice
cream like what if what a way to ruin
[__] something wonderful man you
might as well put rabbit [__] [__] in
it as well and then she goes uh have you
ever had
rum raisin and I was like no no because
why would I eat something with raisins
in it why would I I don't even eat
Raisin Bran let alone why would I eat
ice cream that's two things I don't
[__] ingest rum and [__] raisins
so no I've never had rum raisin [__] it
and she's like okay all you need to
remember for the rest of your life to
navigate this world is that you will
always be somebody's rum raisin Kevin
like they're not even going to taste you
you're just not their [__] ice cream
they just don't want you it's going but
you're gonna be a lot of people's
[__] what is your favorite I said
Oatley chocolate she's like you're gonna
be a lot of people's Oakley chocolate
and just accept that move on and that
[__] changed my life that you know
that's a golden nugget of information
that has made life more easy to navigate
for me understanding that like same
vitriolic reaction I had to Rum raising
where I was like what do you [__] I
hate it and I've never taste it same
[__] thing man I will always be
somebody's rum raisin
I don't know how but the spiderverse
will be somebody's [__] rum raisin
The Flash with Michael Keaton is Batman
let's just call it the Michael Keaton
his Batman movie will be somebody's rum
raisin it is confounding to me but
that's just the way it is some people
will never even [__] bother trying it
and [__] and that's
true of every [__] movie so every
movie is somebody's favorite [__]
movie and every movie is somebody's
[__] rum raisin and the key to life
is to not give a [__] if somebody's like
ew that shit's from raisin it's like
right on moving on [__] sucks to be
you because I find magic in it I find
that [__] tasty and if you don't like
I'm not gonna try to convince you
otherwise like that's what social media
has become a bunch of people trying to
convince other people that they're
[__] right there is no [__] right
and there is no [__] wrong it's all a
matter of [__] Personal Taste we're
not in competition with one another
we're all on the same [__] plane
there's no goddamn ladder and nobody's
more right than [__] somebody else
except the people who are into like
Nazis and [__] those [__] but like
when it comes to Art Mark right Proviso
Nazis are always wrong
and appreciating fun things you know if
you don't like it like
I'm not I'm not saying I pity you and
you're a [__] idiot but it's like all
right that's not where your Joys fell
perhaps your joy is held someplace that
it's not for me
um
this movie is not my [__] rum raisin
it is definitely my [__] chocolate
Oatley and I will [__] I'll put
peanut butter in that [__] and eat it
all day long uh and I bet you the flash
is going to be that as well I'm telling
you right now even if every second of
the flash [__] sucks except for the
seconds that Michael Keaton is playing
Batman
I'll forgive I know it's like two hours
and change and somebody's like Michael
Keaton's only in 50 minutes of it I'm
like only
we were never gonna have Michael Keaton
back as Batman that was it we had seen
every [__] possible second of Michael
Keaton as Batman stories and now through
some [__] shift in the universe we
get a whole other chapter to his Batman
I'm [__] beside myself happy about
this [__]
any event Little Mermaids long there I
said it I said it
um I I don't remember we we were uh you
were a Ted lasso kid right like you got
back on board I [__] love Ted lasso
I couldn't remember if that was a thing
during the pandemic that I was like you
should watch this and you said I will
and then you never did
um which which happens occasionally
um I can't I don't know if you were the
one who told me to watch it I did I
watch no you I think you did watch it
before me yeah because I remember
talking about it on the cast and uh
you're like I've never again I was like
hey Mark said this was good there were
two things during the pandemic remember
what was the other movie with the guy
with the motorcyclists and [__] Matt
Mickelson oh Madge Mickelson yeah the
[__] name was that one but it was we
keep basically he's playing The Punisher
yes and I was like Mark says this
movie's good my wife was like look I
like Mark but like this looks [__]
bad but [__] we both loved it and I
was like I'll watch anything Mark says
even if Mark was like I found your own
snuff film in which you die I'd be like
Mark says it's good
he says the third act has a big twist
you'll never see it coming
um how did you feel about the the finale
to Turtle beautiful I cried for it it
was [__] wonderful I hated to see it
end I understand how it ended I think
it's ballsy as [__] to use that Cat
Stevens song in a world where you know
[__] it was defined by Guardians of
the Galaxy but that's how good Ted lasso
is and how confident they are of
themselves so they're like yeah we know
this is the Guardians ending song but
we're gonna [__] do it too because
this pre-exists the Guardians and it
really works for this
um I you know I they gave them
a bit of the Bad News Bears ending and
the Bad News Bears prepared me from that
from age six as did Rocky but the Bad
News Bears went before Rocky if I
remember correctly
they might be the same year the idea
that your hero will not always [__]
win or Your Heroes so you know they get
to they get to I can't do [__] soccer
football whatever the [__] but they get
their division title is that it but then
and they don't even bother showing them
not winning the other thing right
um but you know there's a Bittersweet
Edge to it there and whatnot but it was
never about football you know what I'm
saying the whole thing's predicated on
[__] footy as they call it over there
let's just say soccer because we're an
American
but it was never about soccer just like
the Bad News Bears isn't really about
[__] baseball at the end of the day
it's just set in the world of
so that aspect alone about like watching
their unlikely rise this season and even
all the seasons of Ted lasso with the
background of [__] soccer slash
football was never the point the point
of that was always about
this guy's Journey this guy who was
hired as a [__] joke
and then the magic that he brought to
that [__] team how that individual
was brought to a place
under
one might almost say cruel pretenses and
was such a powerful force for good that
he changed everybody's life for the
better by the time he leaves it so much
so that nobody wants him to [__] go
it's a beautiful humanistic story and
every episode you know there were some
that were softer than others and stuff
but I would say ninety percent of those
episodes were instant [__] Classics
throughout the Run of their show and I
think the series finale falls into that
category as well it had a deep Landing
to stick in order for you to feel okay
about [__] what happens in the end
and they were able to do what I felt
um
it was it was I thought it was beautiful
nothing really shocking I wasn't like I
can't believe they [__] pulled that
off
um they picked a lane Elaine that I love
to travel in and stayed with it like
they they can legit make you laugh in
that show with some dirty [__]
and it has the purest [__] heart and
that's why I've tried to make my living
for like the last 30 years so I was
geared up to like this show already and
they just did such a wonderful [__]
job you know
I'm sad to see it go but
I'm okay like you know we can always
watch the reruns and [__] like that
um but I'm okay that they chose to to go
out
um especially the way they did it was so
[__] beautiful
um and touching you know and [__]
like they gave us some Unforgettable
characters you know Roy Kent is is a
[__] character for the ages
um you know in his journey the show was
never about him and yet at the same time
watching his journey was a big part of
what that show
was
um you know it had magical [__]
moments throughout the Run of that show
including the dart game in season one I
think it was with with Rupert barbecue
sauce and that [__] was paid off
you know as Ted was watching just when
they got the last call he was like
barbecue sauce and [__] family
I thought who who is who did that show
Bill what Bill Lawrence
um and then scrubs guy so I wasn't
familiar with with scrubs anything like
this did it have a lot of heart it had a
ton of heart you know it was it was
funny at times 100 but there was always
the the underbelly of Scrubs was you
know here's what it's like to be young
and hungry and broke but loving what
you're doing and loving the opportunity
to help change lives and it would get
very serious at times it would be
awesome it was very Parks and Recreation
that way also
where where Parks and Rec was very much
like we're gonna tell this knucklehead
story about these knucklehead civil
servants and it's going to be very very
funny but we are not going to be afraid
to like go deep on these characters and
their love for each other and their love
for the place that they live in and I
think you know Mike Shore who did Parks
and Rec would always say if we made you
laugh for 22 minutes we can we've earned
four or five minutes of emotion like and
if you can't give us that then you just
don't like the show
and so I think Ted lasso was very much
in that mold of like we're gonna make
you laugh but you know the the core of
it was always the relationship between
these people and who they could be
if they allowed a little Ted into their
lives
um and how he changes everybody almost
everybody for the better you know and
helps them on their way
um my I love the finale also you know it
sticked most of the landings that I
would have wanted it to stick the one
quibble I had and I had you know for
most of the season was the mate story
um which I was here for like yeah maybe
a bad guy like I get it like he's he's
he's in a self-loathing person like the
in-cell is high like all of that stuff
was real
um but the quickness with which he was
re-accepted by AFC Richmond was a little
fast for me
um a lot of it is off screen like all of
us players voted and we'd love to have
you come back I said well what about Ted
I don't know why suddenly Nate is Paul
McCartney I know really where'd you
why'd you go all over publicly
foreign
was the one that kind of functioned as
the last holdout
in that when he when he kind of showed
up at Nate's place and then gave his
secret origin for why he was so which is
beautiful which is great you know I just
I think you could have stepped all of
that stuff back so that by the time you
end the show you end it with him finally
being re you ended with the hug with Ted
right you ended with you like I'm so
sorry I I don't know what like he
doesn't say more than I'm sorry Ted and
he forgives it but Nate being welcomed
back as soon as he was was a little
um it felt like you you were forcing a
little bit to give everybody a happy
ending
um but no I was down for it like it's a
fairy tale at the end of the day
somebody online I think the Ted lasso
finale has been analyzed almost as much
as across the spider versus being
analyzed but there was one one person
who's like it's it's it's uh it's The
Wizard of Oz
like Ted is wearing the red shoes that
Dorothy wears Ted like beard is his Toto
like there's literally the Legos of the
yellow brick road like he's putting
together Legos of the AFC Richard and
stuff like it's all kind of there so
it's a fairy tale
for it to end the way it ended a little
bit bitter but mostly very very sweet
for Rebecca to run into her weird you
know uh Amsterdam you know sort of one
night not really Stan thing like just at
an airport you know like get a name so
I'm gonna have a life together the
family that she'd been prophesied by the
the furies in the beginning of the
Season like all that stuff is super
super sweet and I don't I don't begrudge
a show for being sweet
I put you on mute because they're doing
some work right outside my office if you
hear like a high-pitched meme
um
somebody in the chat said something
um Tom C said the most important lesson
was that he had to learn to make time to
take care of himself Ted and that's
that's what they tried to teach me when
I was in Sierra Tucson like put your
mask on before you
help somebody else put their mask on
like you're no good to anybody unless
you're good to yourself first and Ted
was a people pleaser you know Ted put
everybody before himself and because of
his father's story that a lot to do I
thought the episode with his mom was
really beautiful
uh yeah for that reason alone where he
got to address like you know where he's
just like I love you and [__] you and I
love you
um because she kind of her reaction
to
her husband slash his father's death
shape the rest of Ted's life
and you know made him who he is in a
great way but also made him who he is in
the ways that he would like to have
changed as well
um
you don't know it's crazy being a parent
because you have no idea how you're
gonna [__] up your kid
until it's all done and and it's never
all done because in a moment what looks
like oh [__] when I taught my kid [__]
them up years later it could be not bad
at all you know I don't have that
fraught relationship with my parents
when I was in in The Nut House
they try to get it your parents because
that's generally where most people you
know [__] fall off the rails and [__]
but my I couldn't point to a single
thing that my parents did that like
[__] me up other than modeling and
possibly [__] good marriage for me
where I was like oh well that's what I'm
supposed to do and that's how I'm
supposed to be and I don't even fault
them for that so like it's always tough
for me
when um you know characters are like oh
my parents [__] me up but I thought
Ted lasso handled that very well in the
case of his dad it's very easy to see
how you know that could affect him but
him kind of going at his mom I bristled
that a little bit but completely
understood
um wonderful storytelling in that entire
show a lot of people in chat are
pointing to shrinking you know which is
Bill Lawrence's new show on Apple that
he does with with uh Brett Goldstein Roy
Kent himself that's got Harrison Ford in
it and Jason Siegel have you [__] with
that yet I haven't yet I haven't yet I
haven't I haven't [__] with much of
Apple's content and not for you know not
because of any real thing against it
just whatever reason like it just never
I'm never the guy who just like oh I'll
just let it run show me the next thing
I'm always bouncing out of the out of
the app so I've never tried shrinking I
haven't tried
um Silo which I'm curious about I
um slow horses which I'm also very
curious about is Gary Oldman spy thing
um
yeah it's my fault really it's not their
fault Reggie extra one says I was never
complimented never supported here man
I'm gonna compliment you and support you
right now as Brave to admit
and I support you unless you're like you
know [__]
the white race is the master race or
whatever [__] and I don't support that
you know if you're like let's hunt
children you know I don't support that
what compliment to you is like it's bold
to [__] talk about that and that's
where it begins Healing Begins with
admitting or talking about what
you feel your your loss was and then you
start rebuilding from there you can do
this kid
um in chat they said uh this is Ford's
best acting in years on that show
shrinking a lot of people saying
shrinking is great we should watch
shrinking and
uh the Lang Liam Neely says apple is
replacing Max Sans HBO Sans HBO for me
most of their stuff is amazing uh I know
we gotta go soon because I think JC's
got [__] to do Banff man you got to get
out or something like that
yeah I've got trivia tonight
uh I I probably got half hour left
um let's do uh uh we'll wrap we'll start
wrapping up we can't [__] with a man's
livelihood Batman's guy right tonight if
you're in the Los Angeles area in
Hollywood you go down to the scum
villainy Cantina on Hollywood Boulevard
Banff man's doing some goddamn trivia
man ain't nothing more fun than getting
Sauced up and being like [__] season
two of foundation you know [__]
whatever [__] like that's that's the
kind of thing it is right man yeah I uh
I write all of it so it's all pop
culture it's not like when you go in and
they quiz you entirely about sports or
the Bible or history of Western
Civilization it's all uh pop culture
stuff
do you think there are Pub quizzes where
it's all about the Bible
no but when you go in it's a lot of like
Jeopardy questions so you get a lot of
Bible a lot of like history of World
Civilization stuff like that and we like
my categories tonight are Rotten
Tomatoes 2011 edition so I go in and I
pull uh movie descriptions from Rotten
Tomatoes and I take the names out and
you have to guess what movie it is then
I've got a uh John Williams round
and then uh I always do a what's the
connection where I ask nine random
questions and then if you get all the
answers right it connects in a strange
way
now you're just showing off how big your
dick is
Ben Wellington in chat says JC runs a
great trivia game his May the fourth
questions were rough
um
uh Justin Hickman says the new Ahsoka
trailer just dropped on the NBA Playoffs
any thoughts I didn't see it did you I
think they're doing the show did it just
oh I know they they did reveal the
release date
um which I think is August 23rd August
23rd yeah
Liz Gonzalez and chat says Kevin and
Mark please wish me a happy birthday
it's on the 29th happy birthday Liz
happy birthday Liz
um should we do our last ad before we uh
oh yeah
oh good point man that's all right we
gotta pay our bills kids and our final
ad of the evening before we dive into
everything else we want to thank
we couldn't be having this discussion we
would literally be silent were it not
for the good Folks at Blue chew ladies
and gentlemen how well does Bluetooth
work you get a month free so you might
as well try it you're gonna like it and
so will your partner
blue chew man this episode is sponsored
by Blue chew Let's Talk About Sex babe
big guys remember the days when you were
always ready to go and when I said go I
mean [__]
now you can increase your performance
and get that extra confidence in bed
listen up
Bluetooth
man Bluetooth is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra Cialis and Levitra
but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost have you ever sat
there and been like God it cost me a lot
of money to get a hard on well [__]
Bluetooth is like we're gonna save you a
few bucks man you can take them any time
day or night so you could plan ahead or
be ready whenever an opportunity
arises see get it
the process is simple kids sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved
um you'll receive your prescription
within days the best part it's all done
online so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations where
you're like my dick won't get hard and
he's like all right all right calm down
uh and no waiting in line at the
pharmacy God I hate that nothing I hate
in this world more than waiting in line
at a [__] pharmacy with a soft dick
oh with yes with a very soft dick that
I'm like when will it get hard Bluetooth
tablets are made in the USA God damn it
they're patriotic
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a very discreet package in the
current version of the brown paper
wrapper that you used to get a Playboy
magazine in when I was a child and
Marvel Comics to be fair Marvel Comics
would ship in a plane Brown rapper as
well no backing board
literally just wrapped in [__] paper
it's dead wrapped in paper
um you could be missing out on the best
sex of your life and you probably are
with Bluetooth men everywhere are
excited to see the postman because when
your packages arrive you are packaged
has arrived this is a good ass writing
man this is better than [__]
spider-verse writing they always say
first impressions are important what
about Lasting Impressions
you want to be remembered for your
cocksmanship youtube.com they say
there's nothing sexier than confidence
and Bluetooth can help give you
confidence where it counts in your hard
dick take over mark
so Bluetooth wants to help you have
better sex discover your option to
bluetooth.com chew it and do it we've
got a special deal for deal for our
listeners try Bluetooth free when you
use our promo code Fatman at checkout
just make five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com
promo code Fatman to receive your first
month free
[Music]
that's right when you chew Bluetooth man
your [__] dick is like Roy Kent
it's here it's there it's every [__]
where
uh bluetooth.com kids they're the
sponsors of the back half of the show
uh so give a give them a try man
somebody must be trying them on the show
because they're continuing to be a spot
they've been a sponsor for like well
over two years at this point right I
believe so yeah so for as many people in
chat who are like I wouldn't do that I
mean there are a bunch of people who do
do it
non-discreetly getting their dick hard
exactly they're like [__] you know I
ain't here for the Spider-Man talk I
want to hear how to cure my [__]
softness
bluetooth.com folks how well did
Bluetooth work you get a month free so
you might as well try it you're gonna
like it and so will your partner
bluetooth.com is the place to be kids
and we thank the good Folks at Blue chew
uh for sponsoring the back half
the sexy half of the fat man beyond this
week thank you Bluetooth
gobble gobble that's what she said thank
you
um okay
um
bamf yeah I I have some news because
people ask me all the time
uh and I don't think we talked about it
did we talk about it last show Galactic
star Cruiser is closing
I got a reservation for the second to
last
check-in date you're going I called I
called in I called around I got I cashed
in some favors and I'm going the second
to last so I'm going uh end of September
how much uh it is my room for uh me and
two other people is uh six thousand
bucks
holy the [__] for like two nights
but who are the other two people your
wife and child
no uh which there's a funny story no no
Galactic Starcrest with Jason yeah who's
going instead uh my friend Elliot uh
who's a massive Star Wars fan and my
friend Jazz who lives in Norway who
overslept and missed his flight to Star
Wars celebration London so he's gonna
come over here and spend that money on
this instead well [__] you see if
you're gonna go on the galactic star
cruiser with two guys bluetooth.com
where you're gonna have to visit my
friend um tell you what so you're so six
grand for the [__] stay your portion
is two grand I got you covered I'm gonna
give you two thousand dollars man so it
ain't gonna cost you dick because I know
you always wanted to go and I said I
would [__] pay for you I appreciate
that the uh it's funny I was so excited
when I got the email that I got on I was
like oh my gosh I'm so excited and Jen
was in the kitchen and Josh and I were
sitting having lunch at the dining room
table and she goes dada are you taking
Mom on your trip
I was like actually honey no I'm not she
goes oh oh oh
is that kid like talking now real
sentences and [__] yeah it's pretty wild
uh she's she's like a little human she's
two and a half but she's really just
it's a little human a little human with
a lot of common sense
I'm bringing Jazz for some reason
I've never met him but he's Norwegian
and cool to be fair I asked Jen first I
said do you want to go on this and she
goes no it's okay if you take a boy's
trip bro that's a trick what are you
[__] new to this world every type of
woman says no you know what she means
yeah I better be going on the galactic
starters you're gonna pay for this [__]
when you come home her follow-up was uh
do you think I want to go spend three
days in a hotel without windows
I was like
they sound interesting there's Windows
we're in space
all she has to do is like turn on the TV
and stare at it for three days same
effect she wants to go to Harry Potter
world out there so that will do that at
some point well I ain't paying for that
but I will pay for it star Cruiser um I
want full [__] reportage which we
were gonna get anyway I will I'm going
crazy though I've I've commissioned like
five or six costumes to bring I'm going
all in
yeah I'm gonna be so I'm gonna be in
Star Wars for three days like dress it
play it a purple thing yeah you're gonna
be like [__] uh Baron harkonan in the
latest Dune man just dip yourself in the
Star Wars oil wow but nobody I mean
it'll never there's never gonna be
anything like this again so like
I gotta try I gotta say that's true they
[__] tried it and it didn't work so
they're canceling that [__] so
good for you man that's awesome we were
yeah on the last show we were talking
about like how you missed it and [__]
but you didn't miss it after all I I I I
weasled my way in right at the next one
dreams do come true [__] you know and
now you can answer that Immortal
question JC you just got the last seat
on the galactic star crew what are you
gonna do next I'm going to Disneyland
they are connected one and the same well
that's [__] awesome man good for you
congrats too bad like you're gonna come
back blow this thing with two [__]
hands and they're not going to be able
to sell any tickets off of it and nobody
yeah nobody else will get to go
um somebody asks is Disney isn't Disney
known for people for being super shitty
about people bringing their costumes you
can do it on the star Cruiser I had
um
I have a couple people come into the bar
who I'm acquaintances with who I guess
somebody from
uh overseas with lots and lots of money
paid them to wear their full costumes
and go with them as part of their voyage
so my friends were posting all of these
photos of them like dressed like Greedo
and all this stuff on the galactic star
Cruiser for two days
and they had their entire their flight
the star Cruiser trip and they got paid
each like 500 bucks a day to go on this
trip with these rich guys so the rich
guys could fill out the star cruiser
with Star Wars aliens
how crazy is that
I want that kind of money
me and Mark are out of work writers I
got no scratch I'll dress up like
whatever [__] they want Porkins
admay whatever I'll do it it's made you
got it
French made in space
um check you out man that's good news
that's good ass news that's all I
thought about or commenting on the
Skeletor painting behind me uh who came
from Tim Sheridan one of our co-writers
masters the universe Revolution and uh
uh my co-writer on Master of the
Universe of Revelation the sequels here
coming soon did he paint that or did he
just buy it he hand painted that [__] no
he just bought it it's not even a
painting it's like a print so you could
probably Google naked ass Skeletor and
probably find it online or something but
it's wonderful piece
um all the artists come off my walls
because as I said earlier we're getting
ready to sell the house and stuff and
it's got to get painted you see all the
[__] nail holes in this [__]
literally I'm not even referencing Mr T
but I pity the fool who has to pull all
these nails out fill them holes before
the painting even begins but that piece
um did not go anywhere uh it's I need it
sexy that's my jerk off piece right
there I pop a blue shoe and I'm like
the Bluetooth it's a free ad out of that
[__]
um
all right
I just got lost I was reading the
[__] chat do we want to uh hit a
couple quick questions
uh we should man we should
all right I should
remind folks before we do that this
weekend if you're in Texas
come see me at Fan Expo Dallas me and
Mew is going to be there we're doing Jay
and Silent Bob get old on Friday night
we're taking pictures on Friday we're
taking pictures on Saturday we're
signing [__] and then two weeks after
that me and a whole bunch of [__]
abuse cute folks are going to be in
Michigan at astronomicon
um it's like [__] that's Jen's first
con my Jen she's going to be there and
[__] Jennifer's like nobody wants to see
me I was like you've been in nine
[__] movies like you've been in more
movies than some people who [__] live
at these cons so you can come her me my
kid Brian o'holler and Jeff Anderson my
other child Jason Muse I think Jason
Lee's at that I know for a fact Jason
Lee's at that con as well
um so come on out to astronomicon if
you're in the Michigan area that's two
weeks from this weekend
and if you want to see all those people
on the high seas well have you looked
into Jay and Silent Bob's Cruise Askew
that's happening next February 2024 man
we're gonna go from Miami to the Bahamas
Mark's going to be on that cruise aren't
you Mark I will be my first ever Cruise
you've never been on a boat before nope
I went to Alaska once with my wife 11
days
too much
look I would have preferred to be on the
galactic Star cruise looking at a
[__] TV screen for three days 11 days
is too much um you know by day seven we
were like we get it and we still had
four more days to go but uh go to Jay
and Silent Bob's Cruise askew.com or
cruisesque.com I don't know where it is
you go to ceasemod.com there's probably
a listing for it but come join us
February 2024 man it's cheaper than that
[__] Star Wars [__] Cruise I'll
tell you that and unlike the Star Wars
Cruise it exists still next year
don't look out the windows yes see
what's out the windows we've got
Hollywood Babylon on the high seas we
got fat man beyond on the high seas we
got James on Bob good old on the high
seas we got education with Danny
mcelfish on the high seas plus all your
favorite stars from [__] view SKU
movies and [__] like that me Jay
Dante Randall [__] so many more
they're announcing two new ones this
week we're absolute gets as well as a
band that is an absolute get so if you
haven't gotten your tickets yet pay
attention this week when they announce
[__] the new additions and I
guarantee you're getting back
am I reading between the lines and the
band this new edition
that's right
we're getting the original lineup too
man Bobby Brown's gonna be there now we
do not have new edition
I am not that [__] powerful I can't
even pull
let alone New Edition boys come in
um now you know yo slip hello
um and then uh if you're in the New
Jersey area well if you're in California
June 19th me and Mark are going to be
doing fat man Beyond at the uh Cantina
right there in Hollywood on Hollywood
Boulevard this coming villainy Cantina
and if you're in New Jersey July 15th
16th and 17th come watch The Flash with
me every night at seven o'clock I'm
gonna do q a we're gonna do auctions you
can win some cool [__]
and when I say win I mean buy
um and then don't forget July 1st we're
doing uh uh uh
Bears driving that's mod Castle the
clerk's cartoon marathon with Brian
O'Hara and Jeff Anderson
July 29th we're celebrating my birthday
by reading the Superman live script
at smod Castle
um and August 25th me and Mark are going
to be at smodcast Castle Rock and fat
man beyond live in New Jersey again had
such a good time in March a lot of
tickets already sold for that [__] man
so don't hesitate get your ticket now
and then August 26th if you have not had
enough of me and Mark Welcome to our
double feature our Tim Curry double
feature man keep calm and Curry on where
we're gonna watch not one but two Tim
Curry movies back to back with a q a
[__] sandwiched in between that's
clue at first and then Legend after that
two great Tim Curry movies for the price
of one come on out all the action is
it's mod
castlecinemas.com all right bamf man
let's take their questions all right
Banff
um
first question uh from Graham bliley
what spider entity would you be and from
what kind of universe
Define this question meaning like uh if
you were to be like Spider-Man Noir or
spider punk what spider entity would you
be and what would the universe look like
that you're from
Lego Spider-Man
I would be silent Spider-Man
that's where I take my [__] IP Silent
Bob and I cross him with [__]
Spider-Man and basically the character
talks like he used to talk on the
electric company
he don't speak he thinks and they put
word balloons over his head and then
you'll see his thumb he'd be wearing a
long trench coat and [__] he would have
a backwards baseball cap long hair you'd
have a beard sticking out of his spider
mask and [__]
silent spider Bob
um and it'd be set in the Across the
esque Universe
[__] he would interact with Jay would
be my Green Goblin
or my Gwen Stacy I'm not quite sure my
[__] Mary Jane let's be honest
um let's see uh [__] Dante and
Randall would be my
I don't know who they'd be but they'd
all be their kids because here's the
chance to cross my IP intellectual
property with Marvel's IP they'll make
action figures and [__] like that silent
spider Bob could be as big as [__]
spider Punk I'll tell you that right now
nice Lord and Miller
call me I know how we can make a billion
dollars
I know there are a lot of talented
artists listening
somebody [__] Tweed up that silent
spider Bob variant and I will [__]
retweet that [__]
and make you famous for 12 minutes on
the internet
[Music]
uh I don't have anything quite that good
um I feel like however like
armchair Spider-Man detective at large
would be kind of cool where he just
never leaves his uh his smoking room he
wears a robe the TV channel yeah like I
think her problem is
you didn't account for the fact that
gravity operates differently in this
world
go catch him to Chief O'Hara or Captain
Stacy or whoever your name is that's all
I do sit in armchair and give advice to
the real Detectives
and then use my webs to like get their
doordash food from the front door
um there's your answer kids
um also uh we should point out that the
Flash
the CW is The Flash the arrowverse
[__] ended it's over
it's done I'm not gonna say it's never
happening again because you know in this
best of all possible worlds everything
[__] comes back Michael Keaton is
back as Batman so if that's the case you
may indeed one day see Grant Gustin as
the flash again and the arrowverse May
breathe again but they did end after
nine Seasons they went out
uh they referenced the episode that I
made with the great Zack stance he wrote
the script uh called um
the uh
what was the dinosaur thing or something
oh yeah runaway dinosaur like at one
point you know Barry's talking to his
his baby and they showed the book and
stuff the little baby book of the
runaway dinosaur
um I've got great wonderful memories of
working on the flag I got great
wonderful memories watching it you can
watch I don't even it don't even have to
be remembered this video of me online
watching the you know finale of season
one crying like a [__] child it was
so beautiful and I aggregated from fan
to working on that [__] show got to
meet my heroes in real life and uh help
tell the story back in Seasons I think
two and three
so uh yeah man it's all great things
come to an end and that came to an end
uh The Flash
had his final run on TV just in time for
the flash to start his run at the box
office so
we salute
uh the berlante verse which really
[__] you know for a while there was
doing the Lord's work man
like you know now we live in a world
where Multiverse is a cinematic term and
[__] we're gonna see from what I've
heard in the new Flash movie some
amazing [__] [__] involving movies
that never even happened they're gonna
reference as Flash races across time but
I'll never [__] forget seeing you
know Flash run and catching a glimpse of
The Flash Museum
like that was [__] mind-bending to me
I'll never [__] forget
um Tom Kavanaugh as eobard Thon
the reverse flash sitting in his cell
[__] telling him so run Barry run
um show had such wonderful [__]
moments and episodes and uh yeah it came
to an end so congratulations
to all my flash friends uh in front of
the camera and behind the camera
the folks who kept that show made it
made him run every episode over and over
again
uh We Salute You you did the Lord's work
man now rest easy speedsters by the end
of that show everybody could run fast
everybody's running it's not like
everybody got a superpower and ship but
uh that's what happens when you go nine
[__] Seasons Grant Gustin must be
Rich As [__] right like
maybe if he spent his money well and you
know invested wisely and saved you know
with dedication
he should be comfortable he deserves
that somebody better put him in
something cool and I'm not people like
you cast him I don't make anything
[__] good
let's be honest I make Kevin Smith [__]
he deserves better after spending nine
years in a cement block [__] telling
you Flash stories but he better give
that guy something good he got he became
married got married and has a family now
he's a [__] dad father and [__] just
like he was on the show
um so yes the flash ended and here we
give it it's due thank you
uh speedsters and uh and the
verilantiverse and aka the arrowverse to
others and [__] he ran the longest flash
was the longest running of all those
shows
nine Seasons that's a hell of a way to
go I met some wonderful friends man
through that [__] show
um you know people I still work with
uh to this day for heaven's sakes
um
you know and and uh I'll I will that
show came along at a perfect time in my
life where it like that was where I
started opening up like I was always
pretty
emotionally open but I just didn't wear
my heart on my sleeve and didn't show
[__] people and that was the show
where I was like [__] I don't give a
[__] if it makes me cry I'm gonna
[__] show the internet that and it
got me a job [__] so anybody who's like
[__] don't cry on the internet [__]
you I got to direct flash three [__]
times because I cried on the internet
man so
I don't give a [__] if I'm your rum
raisin I got to drink the flash cause I
cried
reference to an earlier part of the show
um all right bands man give us some more
questions fam okay keeping with the
spider-verse theme uh this is uh ear
mixing for both Kevin and Mark if you
could come up with alternate universe
versions of Jay and Silent Bob what do
they look like
so pick a different universe and you
have to like redress them the way that
they do with Spider-Man
um in the Mirror Universe they [__]
dress like each other so Jay wears the
long coat
Silent Bob wears sweatpants or track
pants
um
I I mean here how about in the cold
Universe they wear Snow variants
so you know how Han Solo had the [__]
parka thing
that's what [__] Silent Bob wears on
Hoth
those are his hot fatigues Jay's got his
best been fatigues he's wearing like
khakis and [__] like that
No Cap whatsoever I don't know this is a
tough one for me
yeah I mean it's like you can do
tropical [__] James Helen Bob where
where Jay is wearing you know like
[__] bunny bathing suit shorts
and uh or or a thong he'd probably wear
a thong Jay feels like a thong dude and
uh and Silent Bob is still wearing an
Overcoat but he's got
um shorts on which he already has and
[__] sandals you know for the sand
makes sense
all right Batman come on back I would do
Sherlock Holmes and Watson Jay and
Silent Bob and they speak with British
accents and solve Mysteries but in their
High jinxy Way
[__] dude that's good now what do you
think you've had an answer
well done well then in that world I pick
[__] biblical J in Silent Bob
where you know they're they're
like [__] helping Jesus out of jams
and [__] like that they get them off the
cross like Life of Brian James
they [__] they they show up at the
crucifixion with a ladder and a pair of
pliers the Sam Kinison Munch joke they
[__] pull Jesus down and then [__]
Oscar Isaac says some alternate Jesus
shows up and he's like you can't do that
some things are Canon wouldn't it [__]
up how the villain technically in the
Spider-Man movie was like all the people
who like Marvel editorial like who've
told the same [__] story over again
like because they're like you can't
change some [__]
Uncle Ben's Gotta Die Captain Stacy's
Gotta Die and [__] I thought that was
kind of funny
yeah man that's it
uh
are we talking about Dogma I guess I've
done it already you're absolutely right
but hey I've retread myself before we
just came out with clerks three for
heaven's sakes so
all right last question last question
Judas and Jesus into the Judas verse
how many people can he betray uh all
right last question of the night is
going to send us home kids hope you had
a good time this is uh from crispy
Burrell
if the guys could put together a band
musical group comprised of only Comic
characters who would be in the band and
what genre of music would they play
ask another question that's not I ain't
fun for me ask a question we could
[__] answer man like does anybody
have a trivia question or something I
don't want to think of alternate me
[__] animal bands and [__] something
else
uh let's see
a lot of Multiverse questions tonight
let's try um right
what sequel what sequel or reboot what
SQL reboot or update that no one asked
for but you would have carte blanche and
endless money would you do and I'm gonna
add the caveat not another Michael
Keaton Batman
[__]
don't steal my joy and then just
disappear you bam piece of [__] like I
was gonna say Michael Keaton Batman
God damn it all right here I'll throw a
bunch of you Buckaroo bonsai
Bad News Bears I've always wanted to do
a Bad News Bears sequel man we're Kelly
Leak and [__] um
Amanda wulitzer are grown up and they're
the [__] Walter Matthau's and they
both coach separate [__] teams that
got to play each other
Paramount call me there's a bear's
reverse I'm telling you right now a bad
news averse
what other things have I loved [__]
Bob and Doug McKenzie I bring that [__]
back and keep it going
um what else did I love as a child
you know what I always think I felt like
man they could have made a lot more of
those
Halloween no I'm kidding
you know Saturday the 14th Sunday the
15th this is all these calendar movies
you've got to get making
um I I don't I mean I have gotten very
lucky in as much as things I've Loved
really caught on and [__] now they'll
do them to death and [__]
but uh there are some things like
like the things I just mentioned which I
would totally love to
go back into Buckaroo Banzai is just
wide open man they only did it once and
it's so crazy imaginative in my lifetime
somebody's gonna [__] get that and
run with it and make it work
I was attached to it for like four
[__] years five years I think at two
separate places both with money and it
didn't come together so maybe it's me
but we almost had Keanu Reeves doing it
I know so close so
[__] this could have been like John
Wick
I could have been the new John Wick you
could have been you were a pubic hair
away with a guy who made John Wick
really I could never win [__]
somebody [__] like that [__]
takes a beat somebody [__] slaps me
I'd cry and count
so I could never be John Wick himself
um
let me see
Maurice Suggs in uh chat said Buck
Rogers I [__] co-signed that I don't
understand how Buck Rogers Flash Gordon
are not Green Hornet which is another
thing I've worked on and stuff as has
Mark
I don't understand how these are not
[__] happening again here here's a
here's a big one ready
the shadow [__]
how the [__] are they not doing the
shadow now
like just because they made the Alec
Baldwin Movie and people felt like it
didn't work and [__] there's some good
[__] in that movie but the shadow is a
badass [__] character you don't have
to do it in the 20s Howard shaken
[__] didn't do it in the 20s he
updated it for his DC Comics run and
that run of the [__] shadow that
followed his run well one of my favorite
comic book runs of all [__] time
Shadow's got a network of agents and
[__] like that like Lamont Cranston the
original [__] billionaire
[__] with a dark secret and [__] he
changes his voice he has the power to
Cloud men's Minds he's got a [__]
ring come on man all that [__] is gold
due to [__] Shadow do it
what about you mark
um the one that I'll say because the
other ones would be giving [__] away for
free and I don't want to do that I've
been warned against it but
um I uh The Last Starfighter seems like
it was just built to be a TV show or
more movies or whatever but that idea is
so [__] strong
it's so fun you know looking at uh you
know who really wanted to do that while
we were making Zack and Miriam Make a
Porno Seth Rogen was pursuing The Last
Starfighter because he wanted to do that
as a film for the exact same reason he
was like it is such a great idea he's
like especially now what video games
aren't just kiosks in a [__] arcade
they're viable people do it all the time
and get really [__] good at it and
[__]
um yeah that idea plays excellent ideas
I remember uh Gary witta who uh who
co-wrote Rogue one was chasing it and
then the problem had always been the
rights were difficult
um like Spielberg wanted to do it Seth
wanted to do it but I think Gary had
gotten relatively close to finding the
person with the rights and maybe
convincing them but that was a couple
years ago and I don't know whatever
happened with that but it still is like
sort of the nerd Holy Grail of like come
on guys come on it's just sitting there
it is and video games have only become
more [__] popular so the film is
relevant as [__] I mean we bit that
story line for an episode of the [__]
clerks cartoon where Randall played this
game pharaoh and he was so good at it
the government came and they're like
you know you this game was always meant
to find somebody at your skill level and
like in the game all he did was break
rocks and then they brought him to the
system
rocks and get whipped
um there's a new movie coming out called
Gran Turismo which is based apparently
on a true story of this kid who was very
good at playing that video game this car
racing video game so good that he was
kind of dubbed and picked by a dude who
owned a racing team it's like if you're
really good at Gran Turismo I'm gonna
put you behind the wheel of a real
racing car and see how you can do and
apparently he did well spoilers
but I think that's the movie
um
and like that is one step away from The
Last Starfighter it's just like you're
gonna drive Jason gar is supposed to you
know heading up the whatever fighting
zero and the kodan Armada
wow well remembered man great Robert
Preston yes he was absolutely wonderful
um somebody said I kept seeing a bunch
of this and I want to give it a shout
um Rocketeer [__] a hundred percent
hundred percent I would [__] watch a
Rocketeer Sequel and what are they
working on one there's an animated show
I think for Disney plus that they might
have made
um or I I don't remember there was David
or yellow had something to do with it I
think he might have been the mechanic
and they had
yeah I don't know if it was period or
not but yeah Disney was doing something
[Music]
um
somebody said in chat Gran Torino the
Clint Eastwood yes
the video game of just hate speech like
but that guy Batman what's up uh I was
gonna say Last Starfighter but also uh
there's a video game called Wing
Commander that they did a movie of
uh begging like 1999 camel was in it
yeah I think Wing Commander could be
could be a good one
um and also somebody in chat said the
wizard which was a Fred Savage kind of
like road trip video game movie
where I feel like there's a world where
you could do a
a road trip movie about a guy and his
brother and the hijinks of getting from
the east coast to the West Coast for the
video game championship of something
uh bonanista said Home Star Runner and
that just made me [__] like remember
Strong Bad remember Strong Bad writing
all those letters and [__]
um you know a lot of love for the
ThunderCats
um James B Smith says Dick Tracy when
Warren Beatty dies I guess Warren Beatty
has that locked up he's got it locked up
but I think he does the thing where like
every couple of years he's got to shoot
a thing as Dick Tracy in order to keep
the rights like you have to be in
quote-unquote production on something
and so I think he's made like short
films as Dick Tracy that he doesn't show
anybody
is that all right I think so I think so
why is it going on to it like Dick Tracy
would be kind of badass man modern day
Dick Tracy like last year or two years
ago he did a zoom
then he drives as Dick Tracy and that
was
what he like that's why how he got to
maintain the rights he did a zoom
QA as Dick Tracy why is he holding on to
these rights no idea and I don't know
who wants more Dick Tracy except for
maybe Warren Beatty just don't I think
Tracy has the original Rogues Gallery
man
yeah but so [__] flat
Ace I got this two-way watch that's not
as good as my phone Big Boy Caprice he's
got [__] he's got an Apple Watch
before anybody had one blue chew might
want a new Dick Tracy movie oh
but yeah
uh [__] shout out to bluetooth.com
the sponsor for the back half of the
show
and the back half of the show is over
kids
that's all we got for you man don't
forget you gotta come see us live
in Hollywood at the scum and villainy
cantina
right on Hollywood Boulevard tickets at
a very long address that I can't
remember is that Eventbrite just go fat
man see smart as well now
and you better buy them now because
everyone's always like when did you do
to show it to Cantina anymore sell us
out [__] and we will we sold out in
about four days the last show so people
should get on it now
yeah that was show 400 so people were
like oh a reason to celebrate this is
just a show but they should still
[__] buy all those tickets man you
know how many tickets sells this out
tell them man come on in
that's it 75 [__] tickets
here in [__] Los Angeles and
Hollywood
you can come on in you don't even have
to be from Hollywood you'd come in from
[__] Burbank
El Segundo Thousand Oaks [__] Santa
Clarita if you want to push it Malibu
the boo if you will Calabasas
uh
Beverly Hills
they're [__] Beverly Hills
you could just you you don't you could
come see us you'd come in from New
Jersey I'd support that I mean I won't
financially support it but I'd [__]
shout you out put you up on the wall
[__] put a camera on him got you down
[Laughter]
uh whenever we're at smodcast Castle
we're always like who came from where so
many people come from really [__] far
man so don't be shy if you've ever
watched fat man beyond
and you're like that looks like a good
time make a trip
my God like after the show's over you
just hang out with [__] the scum and
villainy cantina they sell blue milk
they got hater tots or tater tots don't
you make food there bath man
we got food we got lots of good food
you forgot your [__] trademark code
word bamf there you go
he's coming from really far away it was
a time delay you can't he must have come
from El Segundo
um and then if you're like what the [__]
I'm on the East Coast I can't get to
that [__] well we thought of you August
25th come see fat man be on its mod
Castle Cinemas tickets it's
modcastlecinemas.com and I'm telling you
right now for a show that takes place in
August it's June 7th that show's on
August 25th it's already over half
[__] sold [__] yeah it is that's
right there's like maybe a hundred
tickets left so don't sleep on it
hey don't forget I'm gonna be back in
Jersey June 15th 16th 17th come watch
The Flash with me hear me [__] scream
every time Michael Keaton comes on
screen in that [__] outfit even when
he's not in the outfit
gonna be it's I'm telling you right now
I've had a good life
and I've I've lived through a [__]
heart attack and I lived through [__]
A Mental Health crisis
and the if in the Story of My Life the
third act the thing that brings it all
together in this when they make the
movie about my life is going to be me in
the theater watching Michael Keaton be
Batman again
so don't you want to be a part of my
movie like you [__] I was there like
that legit happened his life was so
empty that [__] seeing Michael Keaton
play Batman again that's his third act
yeah and Kevin wept yes
it's all I've ever wanted in life is to
see this guy [__] play Batman one
more time
be there in the room with me while I say
I'll be honest with you I'm gonna see it
at the premiere
who are you now yeah I got tickets man
uh I was like I asked my publicist I was
like what am I doing wrong [__] blow
this [__] movie for a year straight
on our TV show and [__] I ain't got
any tickets JB's got tickets to the
[__] Premiere and they didn't call me
and he's like they emailed you and I was
like oh well I don't check my email I
said
yeah so yeah the good Folks at Warner
Brothers invited me to or bended
somebody invited me to the premiere it's
June 12th which is also J Muse's
birthday and it's at the Chinese Theater
literally right down the street where I
have my hand prints and my footprints in
the cement so I'm gonna [__] go look
at my handprints in the footprints and
the cement and walk in and watch [__]
Michael Keaton be Batman again and I'm
telling you if that ain't the [__]
last shot of my [__] the movie of my
life
I don't know what is stableman Style
Just Kevin looking up at Michael Keaton
and then the camera just tilts I don't
know that ain't it Mark because we need
him to go to the show at [__]
smodcastle that's where the movie ends
either June 15th 16th and 17th the third
Act of my movie is unnaturally [__]
long so come watch The Flash with me
watch with Kev The Flash June 15 16 17
and then June 19th Juneteenth if you
will watch me and Mark Bernard talk
about the flash yes Batman Beyond watch
it live at the scum and villainy cantina
hey man can I tell you something else
you know what I got a copy of
Batman Forever the [__] Schumacher
cut oh
that's right so guess what I'm gonna do
I probably shouldn't be talking about
this Warner Bros going to take my ticket
away but I'm gonna slip you a [__]
copy
so you and me can talk about it on that
June 19th show so first we'll talk about
Flash then we can review the Schumacher
cut of Batman Forever I've watched it
it's longer
so it's more of it
you know how the movie starts with
[__] you know I don't remember you
don't remember it starts with two face
um you know [__] busting into the
bank and [__] like that that don't
happen for like 15 minutes in the
original cut
uh it's crazy it's a crazy good copy too
man often Avid it's got like temp score
and everything so on the June 19th show
we're gonna be uh talking about it
excellent you might even show a [__]
clip not online because we'll get there
don't get crazy in the room at scum and
villainy cantina
maybe we do the show and then afterwards
I don't know maybe maybe it winds up
maybe you wind up seeing what we talked
about after the [__] show in the room
when it happens my friends
like the man said
just like Ronnie said be my little baby
that's right
uh all right kids there there's your fat
man beyond for tonight it's now [__]
6 53 on the west coast JC's got to go
[__] ask trivia questions at the scum
and villainy cantina we thank JC for
bringing us to you Banff man himself
right there thin as [__]
somebody gotta look into it [__]
won't eat anymore I'm sure she's trying
to get all fit so we can go on a
galactic starch guys
am I fighting weight crazy
um he's gonna be blue chewing it all
right
we thank the good Folks at bluechew.com
for sponsoring the show we thank the
good Folks at Native for sponsoring the
show we thank you for tuning in to the
[__] show and we thank the Great
God damn it yeah the great Mark
Bernardin for coming in man and [__]
doing the show as per usual I was like
Mark I saw a thing and it made me come
and I love it it's the best thing that
happened and Mark was like whoa whoa
I appreciate your joy
there it is kids bugging you wanted some
you wanted to go Beyond Batman we did we
went fat man beyond and beyond for this
week man uh tune in
for fat man beyond I'm Kevin Smith I'm
Mark Bernard tune in next time same fat
Time same fat channels modcast.com or
youtube.com Kevin Smith Jeff's kiss
everybody
yeah
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Sal Bob get old off Kevin Smith
[Music]